BILL AB ONE SIX THREE HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM THE AGENDA AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
THE FOLLOWING FOR BILLS ARE ON
CONSENT AB.
FIVE FIFTY EIGHT AB FOUR NINE
FOUR A. B. SIX EIGHTY SIX AND
ACR -- FIFTY NINE WE WILL GO
AHEAD -- TO GIVEN THAT WE HAVE
NO QUORUM AT THE MOMENT -- WILL
ASK THE AUTHOR THAT'S PRESENT
HERE TO COME UP AND PRESENT
THEIR BILL.
SO WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON.
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL YOUR
WITNESSES MAY TAKE UP TO THREE
MINUTES FOR THEIR TESTIMONY.
BOB.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU.
SHARE AND SANDERS -- TODAY I'M
HERE TO PRESENT -- D. B.. THREE
FORTY FOUR WHICH ESTABLISHES A
NEW BEGINNINGS CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM HERE -- IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- WHICH IS IT IS
ESSENTIALLY A MATCHING PROGRAM
FOR CITIES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
COUNTIES -- TO ASK FOR A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF MONEY UP TO FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS -- THAT THEY'RE
ALREADY PUTTING UP ON THERE AND
TO TRY AND PUT TOGETHER A
PROGRAM WHILE WORKING WITH --
DIFFERENT WRAPAROUND SERVICES --
TO PUT INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESS
HOMELESSNESS TO WORK BY
PERFORMING SOME TYPE OF CITY
WORK AND WE'VE SEEN THIS HAPPEN
NOT JUST INSERTED CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO -- CERTAIN
OTHER STATES ARE DOING AND OTHER
MAJOR CITIES AROUND THE COUNTRY
ARE DOING AND THEY'VE SEEN A LOT
OF SUCCESS FOR THE FOR THOSE
THAT YOU KNOW REALLY ARE DOWN
AND OUT AND THEY JUST NEED SOME.
WORK TO EARN SOME ONEY TO GET A
PLACE SO THAT THEY CAN THEN MOVE
THEMSELVES OUT OF THEIR
SITUATION OF BEING HOMELESS --
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT HAS HAD A
LOT OF SUCCESS IN IN IN OTHER
AREAS AND SO I THINK THAT IS
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THIS THIS
STATE.
CONSIDERS A POLICY LIKE THIS TO
ALLOW OUR CITIES TO HAVE ANOTHER
TOOL IN ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS --
WHICH IS REALLY IMPORTANT I MEAN
WE WE UNDERSTAND THE SCOPE OF
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S BETTER TO HAVE MORE TOOLS
TOOLS ON THE TABLE THERE HAS TO
BE BY IN FROM THE STATE
OBVIOUSLY OUR BUDGET IS A
REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES.
WHEN IT COMES TO THAT -- AND WE
PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MORE
ABOUT THIS BUT WE JUST HAVE SUCH
A LARGE POPULATION LARGEST OF
ANY OTHERS -- ANY OTHER STATE IN
THE NATION.
GRAND WE ARE THE BIGGEST -- WE
HAVE A LARGE POPULATION SO MAKE
SENSE -- BUT WE JUST NEED MORE
TOOLS IN THIS IS AN EXCELLENT
TOOL TO HELP.
CITIES AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS%
THAT HAVE ACCESS TO A COUPLE
MORE DOLLARS TO PUT TOGETHER
PROGRAM TO TO PUT THE FOLKS ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMES TO WORK AT OR
ABOVE MINIMUM WAGE WE LEAVE THAT
UP TO THE CITY BUT AT LEAST
GONNA BE PAYING THEM.
A MINIMUM WAGE JOB TO HELP LIFT
THEMSELVES OUT OF HOMELESSNESS.
SO -- WHAT THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE IN WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
THAT IS FRIENDS IN DC ON NOW WHO
IS THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
UNITED WAY OF STANISLAUS COUNTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
AS SENATOR CALDERON SAID I AM
THE PRESIDENCY OF THE UNITED WAY
OF STANISLAUS COUNTY PROUD
MEMBER THE UNITED WAYS OF
CALIFORNIA.
OUR STATEWIDE NETWORK OF UNITED
WAYS IS PLEASE A STRONGLY UPHOLD
SUPPORT AB THREE FORTY FOUR BY
SIMPLY MAJORITY LEADER CALDERON
WHICH WILL BENEFIT THE NEW
BEGINNINGS CALIFORNIA GRANT
PROGRAM.
AB THREE FORTY FOUR WILL PROVIDE
MATCHING FUNDS TO ELIGIBLE
SEASON COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENT OR
EXPAND EMPLOYMENT PER WAS FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
AS WE ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA IS IN
THE MIDST OF A HOMELESS CRISIS
WITH THE NATION'S LARGEST
HOMELESS POPULATION AN
INDICATION OF THIS CRISIS IS
SOUTH COUNTY'S AMPLIFIED BY THE
RESULTS FROM OUR POINT TIME
COUNT.
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN ARE
HOMELESS POPULATION IS INCREASED
BY NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
INDIVIDUALS THIS YEAR TOTALING
OVER.
NINETEEN HUNDRED UNITED WAYS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA ARE DEEPLY
INVOLVED IN ADDRESSING LOCAL
HOMELESSNESS CHALLENGES.
THE NEW BEGINNINGS GRANT PROGRAM
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TO MOVE
HOMELESS FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS IN THE HOUSING AND
FINANCIAL STABILITY.
IS OUTSIDE COUNTY WE'VE BEEN
PURSUING A PURSUING A WIDE ARRAY
OF STRATEGIES TO AID THOSE IN
NEED OF HOUSING IS A PART OF
SERVICES.
WE NOW HAVE A TEMPORARY
EMERGENCY OUTDOOR SHELTER WAS
SUPPORT SERVICES AND WE'RE IN
THE FINAL STAGES OF PLANNING AND
ACCESS CENTER AND A LITTLE BEAR
SHELTER.
IN ADDITION THE AYE WAY
STANISLAUS COUNTY IN PARTNERSHIP
THE CITY MODESTO STANISLAUS
COUNTY AND THE COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION I FOUND A HUGE WIN IN
A PROGRAM CALLED DOWNTOWN STREET
TEAM.
BASED OUT OF SAN JOSE THIS
PROGRAM IS NOW IN THIRTEEN
CALIFORNIA CITIES THIS HOMES
WORK EXPERIENCE PROGRAM EMPOWERS
INDIVIDUALS AND ACTS AS A
STEPPING STONE.
INTO EMPLOYMENT HOUSING AND A
BETTER LIFE IT ALSO BENEFITS THE
ENVIRONMENT AND OUR COMMUNITY BY
PROVIDING CLEAN UP ALONG ALLEYS
STREET AND OUR DOWNTOWN AREA.
THE PROJECT BEGAN FEBRUARY
EIGHTEENTH AND CURRENTLY THERE
ARE THIRTY FIVE HOMELESS TEAM
MEMBERS INVOLVED WITH FIFTEEN ON
A WAIT LIST.
IN NEARLY FOUR MEN'S MEN'S TEAM
MEMBERS HAVE WORKED OVER FIVE
THOUSAND HOURS HAVE COLLECTED
WELL OVER FORTY THOUSAND POUNDS
OF TRASH. FOR THEIR WORK THEIR
PAIN GIVE CA BASIC NEEDS.
TEAM MEMBERS BILL CONFIDENCE
RECEIVE HOUSING AND JOB
PLACEMENT COMPLETE RESUMES AND
SET GOALS PLUS.
THEY RECEIVE MANY OTHER
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
HE MEMBERS HAVE ALSO TAKEN ON
LEADERSHIP ROLES.
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DOWNTOWN
STREET TEAM MODESTO PROGRAM
STATED MANY HAVE GONE FROM VERY
LITTLE MOTIVATION FOR WORK AND
OTHER GOALS TO BE HIGHLY
MOTIVATED.
SUCCESS ALSO LOOKS LIKE A VET
NAME RAY WHO HAD TWENTY PLUS
YEARS IN MANUFACTURING CAREER.
AFTER GETTING LAID OFF HE FOUND
HIMSELF HOMELESS IT WAS NOT
AWARE THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR HIM AS A HOMELESS
FAT.
HE STARTED WORKING WITH THE
DOWNTOWN STREET CASE MANAGER
RECENTLY HE RECEIVED A HOUSING
VOUCHER.
AND DOWNTOWN STREET IS WORKING
WITH HIM TO FIND AN APARTMENT.
I HAVE SEEN FOR MYSELF FOR MY
WORK IN STANISLAUS COUNTY THE
TRANSFORMATIVE POWER THAT CAN
PICK COMPENSATION FOR A DAY'S
WORK.
FAIR WAGES INCLUSION AND DIGNITY
HAVE TO BUILD SELF ESTEEM LEFT
INDIVIDUALSUP AND OUT OF
POVERTY.
FURTHER AND PERHAPS MORE
IMPORTANTLY PROGRAMS LIKE
DOWNTOWN STREET TEAM AND THE
ONES ENVISIONED AND AB THREE
FORTY FOUR WILL DEMONSTRATE
THEIR VALUE TO THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES.
AB THREE FORTY FOUR WOULD ALLOW
LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO RESPOND
EFFECTIVELY TO THEIR UNIQUE
NEEDS AND TO BUILD ON THE
SUCCESSES COUNTY LIKE OURS HAVE
RECEIVED HAVE EXPERIENCED.
IN THE WORDS AND ONE OF THE
DOWNTOWN STREET MEMBERS AS HE
DESCRIBED THE PROGRAM TO NEW
MEMBERS AT THEIR WEEKLY MEETING
WE ARE HERE TO LIFT YOU UP AND
TO LIFT YOU OUT OF WHERE YOU ARE.
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME
UP AND STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION.
THE MEASUREMENT KEITH ON HER
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION I APPRECIATE THE
WORDS OF THE UNITED WAY WOULD
JUST ENDORSE THEM AND ALSO SAY
THAT WE AGREE THAT.
PROVIDING PEOPLE PASSED TO BE
EMPLOYED IN INVESTED IN
THEMSELVES IS ANOTHER GREAT TOOL
TO GET A HOMELESSNESS WE NEED TO
USE ALL THE TOOLS WE HAVE.
TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS AND WE
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
TAKE A BREAK A WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERIC FLOOR AS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OF THE
FORTY FIVE LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S IN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WE HAVE ANY OF WITNESSES HERE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
ARE THERE ANY FURTHER WITNESSES.
SO -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
AT THIS MOMENT WE DON'T HAVE
QUORUM.
BUDGET -- ONCE WE I HAVE QUORUM
WILL GO AHEAD AND TAKE UP THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CENTERS
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME SORRY
PARDON ME CLOSE.
WOULD YOU LIKE -- TO COMMENTER
ASK ANY QUESTIONS TO MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE.
NOT [inaudible]
OKAY.
FEEL FREE TO CLOSE THIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OF OPEN THE
TIME IS APPROPRIATE THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
FOR OKAY.
SO NEXT UP IS THE A. B. FOUR
FOUR SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON [inaudible]
WELCOME.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT A
VALID THANK WHATEVER YOU'RE
READY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MEDICARE THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY AND MEMBERS --
TO BE HERE -- PRESENTING -- AB
FOUR FOUR SEVEN WHICH WILL
SIMPLIFY ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESSES FOR OWNERS AND
OPERATORS OF RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES. FOR THE ELDERLY I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
WIENER AGAIN FOR CO AUTHORING.
THIS MEASURE WITH ME AGAIN
APPRECIATE THAT VERY VERY MUCH
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES
PROVIDE.
A COMFORTING SAFE ALTERNATIVE
FOR CALIFORNIANS WHERE THEY CAN
AGE IN A HOME LIKE COMMUNITY.
AND A BEFORE FOR SEVEN UP WILL
MAKE IT EASIER WE THINK FOR
THESE HOMES TO OPERATE AND TO
SERVE.
THESE INDIVIDUALS THIS BILL
INSURERS AND THAT AN OPERATOR
SUCH A FACILITY CAN SEAMLESSLY
TRANSFER AN EMPLOYEE.
WHO HAS SUCCESSFULLY BEEN
CLEARED OF A BACK HAVE A
BACKGROUND CHECK FROM ONE HOME
TO ANOTHER?
THIS ALLOWS EACH OF THE
FACILITIES TO BE MORE
APPROPRIATELY STAFF WHEN AN
EMPLOYEE IS SICK AS A FAMILY
EMERGENCY.
OR OTHER SITUATION.
AS THE LAW IS WRITTEN TODAY A
LICENSEE MONTHS MUST SEEK
APPROVAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO TRANSFER AN
EMPLOYEE ALONG WITH HIS OR HER
BACKGROUND CHECK TO A DIFFERENT
FACILITY.
FROM THE ONE TO WHICH THEY ARE
CURRENTLY.
ASSIGNED THIS PROCESS DOES NOT
ADEQUATELY ALLOW FOR LAST MINUTE
STAFFING SHORTAGES OR CHANGES --
SIMPLY CREE X. THAT CREATES
EXTRA WORK FOR BOTH THE FACILITY --
OWNER AND THE DEPARTMENT IF THEY
LICENSE.
DOES TRANSFER AN EMPLOYEE PRIOR
TO APPROVAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT
THE LICENSEE CAN BE FINED.
A HUNDRED DOLLARS PER DAY MAYBE
UP TO AS MUCH AS FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER DAY.
SO AB FOUR FOUR SEVEN WOULD
SIMPLIFY THIS PROCESS AND ALLOW
CARE FACILITY ICENSEE. TO
INSTEAD MAINTAIN A COMPLETE AND
CURRENT LIST OF ALL EMPLOYEES
WITH CLEARED BACKGROUND CHECKS
THAT WORK AT ANY OR ALL OF THEIR
FACILITIES AND WOULD NO LONGER
FORCE THEM TO ASSIGN EMPLOYEES
TO WANT ONLY ONE FACILITY.
AT A TIME -- THESE LISTS WILL
ALSO BE UPDATED AT LEAST ONCE
PER YEAR -- AND MORE OFTEN THAN
THAT IF PROMPTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES I
HAVE HERE TODAY ROCKS AND GOLD
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA ASSISTED
LIVING ASSOCIATION.
AND GEORGE COULD MERION WITH SIX
BEDS -- TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU MEASURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FROM THE
PATTERSON AND SENATOR WIENER --
ADD MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
ROCK SINGLE THEM ACTUALLY
REPRESENTING SIX BEDS AND THERE
A AN ASSOCIATION OF SMALL SIX
BEDS ARE FEWER RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED.
THERE ABOUT TWO THOUSAND OF THEM
AND I'M HERE TO INTRODUCE GEORGE
COULD NEARING AND WHO IS.
A FOUNDING BOARD MEMBER BUT ALSO
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF PUBLIC
POLICY AND LEGISLATION FOR THE
ASSOCIATION.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LIKE TO START BY
THANKING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON.
AS WELL OUR PRINCIPAL COOPER
SENATOR WIENER FOR UNDERSTANDING
IS THIS ISSUE IN CARRYING HIS
BILL ON OUR BEHALF WE THANK YOU --
IS A SOMEONE MATTER MEMBER
PATTERSON POINTED OUT CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES A CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CLEARANCE FOR AN
EMPLOYEE THE TRANSFER TO A NEW
FACILITY BEFORE THE EMPLOYEE CAN
WORK THERE EVEN IF THE NEW
FACILITY IS OPERATED BY THE SAME
LICENSEE.
IPORTANT NOTE THAT
APPROXIMATELY 80% OF
CALIFORNIA'S RCF FEES ARE SIX
BUT FACILITIES.
AND MANY SIX BUT LICENSEES
OPERATE MULTIPLE FACILITIES IN
THE SAME GEOGRAPHIC LOCALE.
IN A SUCH A LICENSE HE HAS AN
EMPLOYEE WHO IS CLEARED AN
ASSOCIATE TO TO AT LEAST ONE OF
ITS FACILITIES BUT FOUND TO BE
WORKING AT ANOTHER ONE OF THE
SAME LICENSES LOCATIONS.
WITHOUT BEING FORMALLY
ASSOCIATED BY CCL TO THAT
LOCATION CURRENT STATUTES RECESS
SITUATION IDENTICALLY AS A
SITUATION WHERE A LICENSEE
ALLOWED A NEW EMPLOYEE TO WORK
WITHOUT ANY CRIMINAL.
BACKGROUND CLEARANCE RESULTING
IN A CIVIL PENALTY OF ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER DAY UP TO
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
HOWEVER AS WE KNOW THESE TWO
SITUATIONS CLEARLY ARE NOT
IDENTICAL AB FOUR FOUR SEVEN
WOULD STOP UNFAIRLY PENALIZING
LICENSEES WHO MAY HAVE FORGOTTEN
TO TRANSFER THE CLEARANCE OF AN
ALREADY CLEARED EMPLOYEE.
WORKING AT ONE OF ITS OTHER
LOCATIONS OR FOR SITUATIONS
WHERE THE LOCAL CCL OFFICE
FAILED TO PROPERLY PROCESS A
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CLEARANCE
TRANSFER REQUEST.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO KNOW THE
WHILE SIX BUT FACILITIES HAVE
HIGH STAFFING RATIOS BECAUSE
THEY ARE SMALL IN NATURE EACH
FACILITY NEVER THE LESS HAS A
LOW EMPLOYEE COUNT ON AN
ABSOLUTE BASIS.
A SUCH AS IMPORTANT FOR
LICENSEES TO BE ABLE TO EASILY
MOVE STAFF BETWEEN ITS LOCATIONS
OUR SPONSOR A VARIETY OF
SITUATIONS SUCH AS WHEN
EMPLOYEES CALL IN SICK GO ON
FAMILY OR MEDICAL LEAVE OR
ABRUPTLY QUIT THEIR EMPLOYMENT.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW LICENSEES
OF MULTIPLE FACILITIES THE
FLEXIBILITY TO QUICKLY MOVE
STAFF BETWEEN US LOCATIONS
THEREBY MAINTAINING THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF RESIDENTS OF BY
ASSURING ADEQUATE STAFFING AT
ALL TIMES WITHOUT RISKING BEING
UNFAIRLY PENALIZED. EIGHTY FOUR
FOUR SEVEN WILL MODERNIZE
CURRENT STATUTE AND BETTER ALIGN
IT WITH THE OPERATIONAL
REALITIES RCF FEES PARTICULARLY
SMALLER CF FEES BASED ON A
REGULAR BASIS WE ALSO BELIEVE
THAT A AB FOUR FOUR SEVEN WORLD
WILL RESULT AND EFFICIENCIES.
THAT WILL REDUCE THE SEALS
WORKLOAD RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I. BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
QUICK PAUSE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RICARDO.
RICARDO HERE STONE.
BELL.
BELL HERE JACKSON.
PAN.
PAN HERE WINNER.
WINNER HERE.
FOR THANK YOU WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED FORM.
OF DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO COME UP US TEACHING HIM
AN ORGANIZATION.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON HEATHER
HARRISON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSISTED LIVING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
THESE ARE COMMON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
CAROL THROUGH FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
THE BILL [inaudible]
OKAY.
FEEL FREE TO CALL IF PART OF
THAT A MINIATURE I'M MANAGER OF-THE THIS IS A SIMPLE
ADMINISTRATIVE FIX.
IT DOES ALLOW RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES -- TO PROVIDE FOR THE
ELDERLY AND TO OPERATE MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND TIMELY PROVIDING
THAT SERVICE.
UP OF THIS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON A BEFORE
FOUR SEVEN THANK YOU.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR PAN TO DO PASSED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HER DAUGHTER HI -- TITLE AYE
STONE BELL.
RIGHT MEL AYE JACKSON.
PAN PAN HI WIENER. THREE SO FAR.
OKAY WE'LL GO AHEAD AND LOOK AT
HOLD IT OPEN THANK YOU
.
WITH.
ALL RIGHT SO.
AND WE'LL GO AHEAD AND TAKE UP A
BE FOR EIGHTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS FEEL FREE TO COME UP AND
BRING YOUR WITNESSES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
PRESENT BEFORE YOU SIMPLY BILL
FOR EIGHTY WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH
AN OLDER ADULT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ADMINISTRATOR. TO
OVERSEE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR OLDER ADULTS.
OUTCOME INDICATORS IN ST CARE
AND STANDARDIZE -- GERIATRICS
TRAINING FOR MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
AS WE KNOW ONE IN FIVE ADULTS
EXPERIENCES MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS HOWEVER LESS THAN ONE
THIRD OF ALL OLDER ADULTS THE
UNITED STATES WHO NEED MENTAL
HEALTH.
CARE RECEIVING WITHOUT ALL
DISCORDANT DEFER TO OUR WITNESS
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME BE HERE -- MY NAME IS
JANET FRANK AND I'M ON FACULTY
AT UCLA SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
I AM PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY --
TO SURE SOME FINDINGS THAT WE
HAVE FROM OUR MENTAL HEALTH A
SERVICE ACT IN OLDER ADULTS
STUDY.
WE FOUND SIGNIFICANT UNMET NEED
AND GEOGRAPHIC DISPARITIES
ACROSS THE STATE IN THE SERVICE
PROVISION TO OLDER ADULTS.
WITH SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS.
WE FOUND VERY FEW PROGRAMS AND
OUTREACH EFFORTS THAT WERE
SPECIFICALLY TAILORED. FOR THE
COMPLEX CARE NEEDS FOR OLDER
ADULTS AN OUTCOME MEASUREMENT
DATA WERE QUITE LIMITED.
HOWEVER WE ALSO IDENTIFIED
PROMISING PROGRAMS OFFERED IN
SOME COUNTIES TO ADDRESS THESE
DEFICITS.
WE ALSO NOTICED THAT THERE WAS A
GAP IN LEADERSHIP AT THE STATE
LEVEL FOR MENTAL HEALTH IN OLDER
ADULTS SERVICES.
BASED ON OUR FINDINGS WE MADE
SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS
INCLUDING TO ESTABLISH A FULL
TIME ADMINISTRATIVE LEADERSHIP
POSITION AT THE STATE LEVEL.
DEDICATED TO OLDER ADULT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
WITH THE PROPER AUTHORITY THIS
LEADERSHIP POSITION COULD
IMPROVE ACCESS AND SERVICES FOR
OLDER ADULTS WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS.
COULD CONTRIBUTE. TO AND OVERSEE
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF STATE
POLICIES TO IMPROVE SERVICES.
PROVIDE NEEDED OVERSIGHT
ESTABLISH STANDARDIZE REPORTING
ENHANCE OLDER ADULTS OUT REACH
DOCUMENTATION OF AND MET NEEDS.
SURE PROGRAMS THAT ARE WORKING
ACROSS THE STATE RATHER THAN
HAVING THEM IN POCKETS OF
COUNTIES.
PROMOTE STANDARDIZE GERIATRIC
TRAINING AND IMPORTANTLY
INCREASE SERVICE INTEGRATION
EFFORTS ESPECIALLY BETWEEN
MEDICAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGING
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE SERVICES TO
PROMOTE.
COMPREHENSIVE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
OUR STUDY SHOWED THAT OLDER
ADULTS HAD HIGH UNMET NEEDS AND
STATE DATA FOR FY EIGHTEEN SHOW
THAT JUST OVER TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND OLDER ADULTS THAT SIXTY
FIVE AND OVER WERE PROVIDED
SERVICES.
THIS REPRESENTED LESS THAN 4% OF
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
SERVED PROSELYTES ROUND.
CALIFORNIA'S OLDER ADULT
POPULATION IS AROUND SEVEN
MILLION.
AND MOST OLDER ADULT PREVALENCE
STUDIES SHOW THAT ABOUT 20% OF
ADULTS OF SUFFER FROM MENTAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROBLEMS.
BUT LET'S TAKE IN A MORE
CONSERVATIVE NUMBER LET'S SAY
10% ROUGHLY SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND YET TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND WERE SERVED.
SO RIGHT NOW NO ONE IN THE STATE
HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE THE
SYSTEM MORE RESPONSIVE. TO THE
NEEDS OF OLDER CALIFORNIANS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS THANK YOU.
HERE I DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
PLEASE COME UP STATION NAME AN
ORGANIZATION.
LAUREN RALPH I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
HELLO I'M TITUS Và SAY -- MY
REPRESENT THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MAURICE REGIS
AND REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
HOUSE WITH ASSOCIATION AND WE
ALSO SUPPORTED THIS BILL.
CAROL SO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING IN SUPPORT
WE DO HOPE TO SEE THE BILL
AMENDED.
AT LEAST IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE
HEARING TO MOVE THE POSITION
BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES BUT WE FULLY
SUPPORT CREATION OF THIS
DIRECTORS.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
RATIGAN ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS FAQ CLARA COUNTY --
I ARRIVED HERE THINKING WE WERE
IN SUPPORT -- I'M NOT SURE NOW
WAS UNAWARE OF THE AMENDMENTS
THAT LIMITED TO SIX SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES.
AND IN LIGHT OF THAT WE WOULD.
THE REQUESTED THE BILL BE
AMENDED TO ADD ANOTHER COUNTY
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
I'M SORRY I APOLOGIZE.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. TO HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR MY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FROM THE
NUMBER FELL -- THE FUNDING FOR
THIS -- THE QUESTION WOULD BE
THE MIL HEALTH SERVICES ARE -- I
JUST WENT OVER THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE REPORT.
AND I WAS SAYING.
HOMELESS PROGRAM FUNDED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES -- GO ALL THESE
OTHER PROGRAMS FUNDED AND ADDED
UP TO OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS SO.
THE QUESTION IS -- SPECIFICALLY
YOU'RE POINTING OUT THAT THE
TOOK WERE SOURCE OF FUNDS RIGHT.
ARE YOU ARE YOU LOOKING AT THAT
SOLELY OR YOU LOOK INTO.
ANY ANY PLACE YOU CAN FIND THE
FUNDS.
DEBBIE THE QUESTION I MEAN YOU
KNOW BECAUSE YOU KNOW WITH ALL.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH THE BUDGET YET
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T VOTED ON IT
RIGHT BUT SEEMS TO ME IT LOOKS
LIKE.
THERE'S A LOT OF DRAW DOWN ON
THAT AND THAT PHONE IN THIS THIS
PARTICULAR BUDGET THAT'S ALL.
AND HAVE THE HAVE THEY LOOKED AT
IT HAVE THEY HAVE THEY LOOKED AT
THIS BILL. TO VIOLATED THE YEAH
TO SENATOR YET NOW THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA --
TO BUT WHEREVER WE CAN GET THE
FUNDING WILL WANT TO DO WITH.
WAS HIGHLIGHT WITH THE
LEGISLATION THE IMPORTANCE FOR
THE SO WHY WE NEED TO DO THAT SO
WHETHER IT'S THE THE FUNDING
MECHANISM THAT YOU'VE OUTLINED
WE'VE ALSO TALKED TO LEADERSHIP.
AND THE BUDGET STAFF AND
CONFERENCE -- COMMITTEE AS WELL
AS IDENTIFYING YOU KNOW YEAH I
DON'T CARE WHERE THE MONEY COMES
FROM AS LONG AS HELPING THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
AND IF THAT'S A DIFFERENT POT OF
MONEY THEN YOU KNOW I WAS I'M
AMENABLE TO THAT JOB AND WOULD --
APPRECIATE THAT BUT MOVING
FORWARD BECAUSE WE HAVE A VOTE
ON THE BUDGET I KNOW IT'S PART
OF THE DISCUSSION.
I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT --%
MANAGER BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW IF
THE WE DON'T KNOW THE STATUS OF
THAT ORDER.
THAT'S JUST THE ONE KIND OF
CAUTIONARY.
NOTE ON THIS ISSUE GRABS.
THEY COULD SAY THIS FUND EARNS
ANY OTHER FUNDS THAT IRAQ MIGHT
BE APPROPRIATE AND THAT
SOMETHING YOU WERE LOOKING TO
MAYBE GET SOME CLARITY ON AS WE
MOVE TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IF IT PASSES COMMITTEE.
OKAY I'M I'M SUPPORTING THE BILL
I JESSICA AT A QUESTION ABOUT
THAT.
THANK YOU AND APPRECIATE --
AMERICANS ALSO TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH WITH THE BILL I JUST
THAT SOME. FOR QUESTIONS
REGARDING HOW THIS OF OPERATE SO
I THINK WHEN THE ISSUES IS -- IS
BROUGHT UP AGAIN ABOUT FUNDING
BE MORE FLEXIBLE Là.
BUT ALSO -- AND WE TALK ABOUT
ADMINISTRATOR BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE
GIVEN THE LIST OF THINGS ARE
SUPPOSED TO DO YOU REALLY
LOOKING FOR A WHOLE OFFICE RIGHT
I MEAN IT'S CAN'T ONE PERSON'S
LACKEY MAIL DO ALL OF THIS IS
THAT WE HAVE IN OUR SOMEWHERE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SIDE SO THEN THE
I GUESS THE OTHER QUESTION IS --
AS THE IS WHY THE APARTMENT
AGING VERSES INDEED C. S. SINCE
DTS NOT ONLY OF COURSE --
OVERSEAS ALL THE MEDI CAL MONEY
BY THE WAY -- FOR MENTAL HEALTH --
ALSO HAS -- PERHAPS A CLOSER
RELATIONSHIP WITH -- THE THE
HEALTH SERVICES -- OVERSIGHT
MISSION AND AND THAT THOSE FUNDS
AS WELL SO WELL CERTAINLY
DEPRIVE AGING DOES VERY POOR
ROLE WITH SENIORS AND WORKS WITH.
THE TRIPLE A.'S -- BUT GIVEN THE
NATURE OF THE THE FOR THIS
MINISTER SUPPOSED TO DO -- MAYBE
YOU CAN ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT ABOUT THAT AND ABSOLUTELY --
YEAH THIS IS A DISCUSSION THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING ON GOING INTO
SOMETHING THAT WE HAD IN THE
POLICY COMMITTEE AS WELL.
OVER IN THE ASSEMBLY ABOUT WORD
WE HOUSES TWO HOUSES THE DCH US
OR TO THE PARTNER OF AGING.
AND YOU KNOW THROUGH THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS AS WHY WE HAVE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE NOW BUT
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY THE THOUGHT
IS STILL BRING EVERYBODY
TOGETHER AS IT.
BEFORE IT ENDS UP BOMB IN ITS
FINAL FORM ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
OUT WERE THE BEST WAY IS TO DO
THAT -- WHAT WE DIDN'T WANT TO
HAPPEN WAS TO HOLD THE BILL AND
PREVENT PROGRESS FROM HAPPENING
ESPECIALLY AS WE'RE HAVING
BUDGET NEGOTIATION TALKS?
AND WE DON'T WANT THIS TO BE A
HINDRANCE AS WELL AS WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO PUSH IT SO YOU KNOW.
HAVE SOMETHING MOVING THE
DISCUSSIONS GO A LOT FURTHER.
THAN THAT SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR
INPUT AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
THAT AS WELL OKAY WELL I THINK I
THINK IT -- ONE OF THINGS THAT.
THE HELPFUL AS HAVING A BETTER
IDEA OF EXACTLY HOW.
THIS THE HOW THE INDUSTRY IN THE
OFFICE WOULD WORK AND A
RELATIONSHIP.
OF OUR FOR TO BE EFFECTIVE RIGHT
RIGHT AND EXACTLY YOU KNOW WHERE
IT'S HOWLS -- THE ISRAELI ISSUE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT HOW HOW'S
IT GONNA BE A PERFORMANCE
FUNCTIONS AND THE RELATIONSHIPS --
THAT THE ADMINISTRATORS GOING TO
NEED TO HAVE SO I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU'RE WORKING ON ESTIMATES
THAT THIS IS I DON'T OF THIS TO
GO TO ANOTHER POLICY COMMITTEE
FROM THIS.
ONE BECAUSE THE HEALTH OH OKAY
WELL OKAY THEN WHO HAS THE TIME
TO FIGURE THAT OUT THEN OKAY.
SO -- I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
THE ANSWERS TO THE QUESTIONS --
AS YOU WORK THAT OUT.
ABSOLUTELY I APPRECIATE THAT
SENATORS WE CONTINUE BEFORE
OBVIOUSLY -- FIND OUT THAT THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE ALSO
SERVES ON HEALTH SO.
WE BOTH WANT TO KNOW.
GREAT NO MORE THAN HAPPY TO
SHARE -- THE DISCUSSION SORT OF
BEEN INVOLVING AROUND THAT AS
WELL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
YOU'RE FREE TO CLOSE OKAY I JUST
WANT.
TO COMMEND DOCTOR FRANK AND ALL
THE WORK THAT UCLA IS DONE ON
THIS ISSUE -- OBVIOUSLY THIS
ISSUE THAT CONTINUES TO GROW IN
TERMS OF THE NEED FOR THE
AWARENESS BUT ALSO.
TRYING TO TACKLE THE ISSUES --
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS FOR
INSTANCE EVEN THE SUICIDE RATES
FOR OLDER AMERICANS AND HOW
THAT'S BEEN INCREASING YEAR
AFTER YEAR -- SHOWS WHY WE NEED --
SPECIFIC FOCUS ON THIS ON THIS
ISSUE AREAS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I'VE.
WELL OKAY GREAT. FOR THE MOTION
FIVE SENATOR PAN TO DO PASSED TO
SENATE HEALTH SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
A TITLE.
I'VE FOR TITLE IX STONE BELL.
BELL I JACKSON PAN.
PAN AYE WIENER [inaudible] THREE
THANK YOU SO WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND OF LEAVE THIS OPEN.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT ON A.
B. NINE SEVEN ZERO PLEASE OKAY.
GO FEEL FREE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AND ASSEMBLY BILL NINE SEVENTY
WOULD HELP PROVIDE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FOR SENIORS AND
THE DISABLED HEALTH CARE
APPOINTMENTS.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH A GRANT PROGRAM WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE FOR THE PURCHASE
OF OR LEASE OF ZERO EMISSION
EARNERS OUR ISSION VEHICLES
PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION TO AND
FROM NON EMERGENCY MEDICAL.
HEALTH CARE APPOINTMENTS FOR
OLDER INDIVIDUALS AND PERSONS
LIVING WTH A DISABILITY.
ELDERLY INDIVIDUALS AND
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
OFTEN HAVE GREATER HEALTH CARE
NEEDS AND TRANSPORTATION CAN BE
PRESENT.
TAKEN PRESENTE SIGNIFICANT --
BARRIER TO CARE -- WITH THAT
IDEA OF TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LAUREN RALPH AND I'M
A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE.
I ALSO WAS -- A CO AUTHOR OF THE
ORIGINAL PROPOSAL AND THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
FOR THIS BILL.
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT'S IT'S A
BILL THAT SORT OF RECTIFY IS A
DISPARITY AMONG.
SENIORS LIVING IN RURAL AREAS
VERSUS SENIORS LIVING IN MORE
POPULATED AREAS OF THE STATE.
AS THE THE ABSTRACT MENTIONS --
MEDI CAL AND PAYMENT FOR
TRANSPORTATION TO AND FROM
MEDICAL SERVICES IS AVAILABLE
THROUGH CAMP TAXI.
PRIVATE TRANSPORTATION BUSES.
TRAINS.
BUT IN THE RURAL POPULATION
THOSE OF THOSE COMMON FORMS OF
TRANSPORTATION OR NOT AVAILABLE
AND IF YOU'RE CONSTANTLY.
RELYING UPON AND A FRIEND OR A
RELATIVE.
VERY OFTEN.
YOU CAN IN THE MISTER
TRANSPORTATION AND THEREFORE
MISTER MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION.
AND THEY GET THE ABILITY TO GET
TRANSPORTATION TO MEDI CAL
APPOINTMENTS.
MEDICAL APPOINTMENTS IS JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS PROVIDING THE
MEDICAL SERVICES THEMSELVES.
I AND IT COULD BE CRITICAL IN.
RURAL AREAS MANY COUNTIES HAVE
LIMITED OR NO TRANSIT SERVICES
AVAILABLE TO NON EMERGENCY
MEDICAL APPOINTMENTS CHRONIC
HEALTH PROBLEMS REQUIRE ACCESS.
TO RELIABLE TRANSPORTATION TO
MEDICAL.
COMPLEXES OFTEN SEVERAL MILES
AWAY SOMETIMES MANY MILES AWAY.
MAKING A SEVEN TO FIFTEEN
PASSENGER VANS AVAILABLE TO
SHUTTLE SEVERAL SENIORS AT A
TIME TO THEIR TREATMENT.
ADDRESSES THIS PROBLEM.
AS IT IS TODAY.
SENIORS IN MANY COUNTY SUCH AS
SAN BERNADINO LAKE COUNTY SAID
NO MY COUNTY MANY.
COUNTIES THAT HAVE A LOT OF
RURAL AREAS.
HAVE TO RECRUIT VOLUNTEER
DRIVERS AND AS WE MENTIONED --
OFF A WE DIDN'T MENTION THAT
OFTEN THE VOLUNTEER DRIVERS ARE
USING.
THE HIGHER POLLUTION OLDER
VEHICLES WHICH CONTRIBUTES TO
THAT OF THE F. ZERO THE
ADMISSION OF CAN'T THINK OF ANY.
IN ANY CASE -- SO THESE
TRANSPORTATION GRANTS TO
COUNTIES OR DEPARTMENTS OF AGING.
COUNTY OFFICES WOULD REMOVE THE
BARRIER TO OBTAINING MEDICAL
TREATMENTS AND IT HERE ALSO TO
THE STATE'S.
PRIORITY TO REDUCE POLLUTION.
PROVIDING THIS NON EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TRANSFER THE PROTECTION
TO THE SENIORS WILL INCREASE.
THE PROBABILITY THAT THEY REMAIN
HEALTHY AND OUT OF HOSPITALS OR
SNAPS.
WE ASK YOUR VOTE TO MAKE THIS
THING HAPPEN.
THANK YOU I DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPELL.
NO CA NINETY WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES OPPOSED TO THE SPELL.
PLEASE COME UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KATHERINE GARCIA AND I'M A
POLICY ADVOCATE FOR SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA.
THE CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN AND
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION --
WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL.
OUR CONCERN IS SPECIFIC.
TO THE USE OF THE TERM NEAR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE.
AND THE BILL THE BILL STATES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING
WOULD RECEIVE DO YOU CHAIR OF
FUNDS. FOR BOTH THEIR EMISSION
VEHICLES AND YEARS ZERO WE ASK
THAT YOU REMOVE NEAR -- ZERO THE
REASON IS GIGI RF IS INTENDED TO
HELP CALIFORNIA TRANSITION TO A
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE WE HAVE
LIMITED TIME AND RESOURCES TO
TACKLE THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
THROUGH INCLUDING NEAR ZERO
VEHICLES IN THIS PROGRAM WITH
UNDERMINED IF.
AFFECTED NESS OF GIGI RF IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THERE ARE
CURRENTLY ZERO MISSION SHUTTLE
SOLD IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE ADA
COMPLIANT.
WHEN IT COMES TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION? ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE PROVIDE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH TO SPEAK
THEIR OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
[inaudible]
NOW.
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CENTER A BELT
WITH.
LISTEN THE ASSEMBLY -- BUILDING.
GET REVIEWED BY THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
THIS.
BUT IT DID BUT IT DIDN'T GET
REVIEWED HERE -- WE HAVE A GOD
THAT THIS IS OUR FIRST POLICY
COMMITTEE ON THE SENATE SIDE.
OKAY -- SEE MY QUESTION WOULD BE
THE THAT'S AVERY THE ISSUE
ABOUT ZERO ZERO ON ZERO THAT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT.
THAT'S A BIG ISSUE BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF LEGISLATION.
IS BEING DEBATED RIGHT NOW ON
THAT INTERCOURSE SUBJECT
[inaudible]
AND IF I MAY SEND YOU TOUCHED ON
OUT IN YOUR BILL IS KIND OF
WONDERING WHY YOU TOUCHING THAT
ISSUE YEAH.
BECAUSE LIKE A SO THE REASON WHY
WE ADDED AT NEAR ZERO EMISSION
IS BECAUSE I INFRASTRUCTURE
DOESN'T EXIST AROUND THE STATE.
TO HAVE ALL ELECTRIC SO WE
DIDN'T WANT TO EXCLUDE THOSE
SENIORS AND RULE AREAS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA -- PLACES
THAT LACK THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
WOULDN'T WANT TO LEAVE THE
SENIORS ON SIDE OF THE ROAD.
NOT BEING ABLE TO GET TO THEIR
MEDICAL PPOINTMENTS.
SO THAT'S WHY WE ADDED THAT I
MEAN IF THERE'S ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES YOU KNOW I GET THE GOAL
OF NUTS WERE MOVING BUT WE
DIDN'T WANT TO EXCLUDE THE
SENIORS -- IN THOSE AREAS THAT
LACK THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
OR FOR SUCH A PROGRAM.
THERE'S ANOTHER WAY GO AROUND --
NOTES THAT -- YOU DON'T JUST DO
A STATEWIDE BLANKET.
COVERAGE OF THAT YOU CAN.
YOU CAN SAY THAT IF THERE IS NO
[inaudible]
ELECTRIC VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
OPTION [inaudible]
THAT.
THE OTHER WOULD BE CONSIDERED
BUT THAT'S KIND OF A POLICY
DISCUSSION YOU KNOW SO.
YEAH -- WEARING WHY THAT THAT
WAS DISCUSSED -- OKAY YES THAT'S
WHY WILL I'M GONNA LOOK AT THIS
AND MY **** IS GO TO MY
COMMITTEE.
YES YOUR ARMS YOU KNOW I DON'T
KNOW WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
OF THE CLEAN AIR ISSUE HERE NOW
SO WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE INCLUDED BOTH VERSIONS TO NOT --
EXCLUDE ANYONE -- HELLO -- OKAY
THIS ZERO INNER SELF.
OKAY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATE.
THANK YOU -- SO CERTAINLY SOUNDS
LIKE THERE'S A TRANSPORTATION
ISSUES TO WORK OUT OF MY
QUESTIONS ACTUALLY HAVE TO
PRETEND SO THE THE GRANTS WOULD
GO TO THE AGING AGENCIES TO
OPERATE THIS VEHICLES.
OR COUNTIES YOU SAID I I WAS
WONDERING FOR EXAMPLE -- WOULD
PUBLIC TRANSIT AGENCIES -- TO
MAY PROVIDE YOU KNOW THE OPERATE
BUT COULD PROVIDE DIRECT TRANSAT
AND ZAID SO I'M SURE IT'S US.
SO THEM THE UNIVERSE OF PEOPLE
WHO COULD RECEIVE THE GRANTS IS
SUCH THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE THE
AIMS OF YOUR BILL WHICH IS.
PROVIDE SO DIFFERENT LOCALITIES
MAY HAVE DIFFERENT.
YOU KNOW WHETHER ORGANIZATIONS
ARE ARE SO FORTH SO -- IF YOUR
AREA AGENTS EIGHT AGING AGENCY
DOESN'T IS USED ARE OPERATING IN
TRANSIT TRANSPORTATION THAT IS
THE SERVICE RIGHT -- BILL WOULD
DAY.
BUT WITH THE GRANT BE ABLE TO GO
TO ARE THEY WOULD HAVETO
SUBCONTRACT THE GRANT WHICH THEN
CREATES MORE ADMINISTRATIVE RED
SIDE SO I JUST WANT TO RAISE
THAT ISSUE IN TERMS OF TO WHOM
THE GRANT TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
ACHIEVE THE AIMS OF THE BILL.
I I APPRECIATE THAT -- QUESTIONS
CENTER ON SOMETHING THAT WE WERE
THINKING ABOUT AS WELL GIVEN --
THE DIVERSITY OF OUR STATE IN
WHICH ELECTIONS IS ACTUALLY DO
THAT SO WE INCLUDED LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL THAT IT'LL.
GO TO LOCAL REGIONAL TRENDS --
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING.
I COUNTY'S PUBLIC TRANSIT
OPERATORS -- AND THAT'S ALL
OUTLINED ON PAGE THREE IF THAT
HELPS OKAY ALL RIGHT I THAT WAS
ENTERED COUNTY AND I HEARD A OR
AGENCY IDEAS AND HEARING THE
TRANSIT AGENCIES AND SOME SOME
OF THE MARK YOU KNOW.
CORRECT SOME PEOPLE LIVE
TOGETHER IN SEATTLE DESPERATE
RIGHT EXACTLY OKAY.
ALL RIGHT BUT WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO SERVICE MANY SENIORS AS WE
CAN OKAY ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SOME OF THE RESULTS FEEL FREE TO
CLOSE -- WE'RE JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR HELP MADE TO
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT AND ALL
THE WORKERS YOU'VE BEEN DOING
THIS FOR HER A COUPLE OF YEARS
[inaudible]
SHE THAT.
SO WHY DIDN'T HEAR I HEARD I
HEARD IT IS OUR PERHAPS FOR
TRANSPORTATION TO HEAR THE BILL
BUT SO.
WE'RE LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW OKAY
ALL RIGHT YEAH BUT THE PROBLEMS.
WELL I GUESS I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS IS THAT WE HEARD SOME
OPPOSITION ABOUT NEAR ZERO ZERO
I HEARD YOUR EXPLANATION.
DO YOU ARE YOU.
ARE MORE THAN HAD PUTTING IN
SOME LANGUAGE PERHAPS THAT SAYS
THAT IF YOU KNOW WE REALLY DO
WANT ZERO UNLESS THERE AND
PERHAPS THAT WILL GET SORTED OUT
LATER ON BYE BYE.
YEAH PROP SO I'M MORE THAN HAPPY
TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION AND TALK
TO CENTER THE BILL OR WHOEVER.
YOU KNOW MY WHOLE THING WAS JUST
NOT LEAVING SENIORS ON SUNDAY SO
I GUESS THEIR COMMITMENT TO ZERO
IF ESPECIALLY IF IT'S AVAILABLE
IN THE REGION THAT THAT THAT
SHOULD BE ZERO AYE AYE A GUY I
GOT THE AND THERE ARE.
SOME NUANCES TO WORK OUT THERE.
THEN I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO BUT IN THE AT LEAST
IN AREAS WHERE THERE IS
AVAILABILITY INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAN THAT WILL BE A REQUIREMENT
THAT IT'S ZERO MORE THAN HAPPY
TO LOOK AT LANGUAGE THAT
ADDRESSESOUT OF MOVING FORWARD
OBVIOUSLY IF THERE'S BEST
AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGY OUT IMAGINE
THE LOCAL.
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES WOULD
MOVE TOWARDS ASSETS SO THAT YES
YES OKAY -- IS A WORKING ON THE
LINK JUST FOR CLARIFICATION THIS
BILL WILL BE GOING TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
EXCERPTED HERE YEAH GOT AUTHOR.
WE HAVE A MOTION -- TO THANK YOU
I WILL MISS OKAY [inaudible]
RIGHT RIGHT.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION -- BY CENTER
PATH TO DO PASSED AS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY US
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PODIDO AYE HURTADO AYE STONE
BELL -- JACKSON PAN I AM HI
WIENER [inaudible] TO TWO POUNDS
USING IT SO WE HAVE TWO ZERO I
WILL LEAVE THIS BILL OPENED --
FOR MEMBERS TO COME IN AND VOTE
THANK YOU YOU ALREADY THANK YOU
CHAIR.
SO CARE CENTERS BALANCE PAN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AB NINE FORTY FOUR WILL REQUIRE
COUNTIES TO RENEW CAL WORKS
BENEFITS. TO AN ELIGIBLE
SPONSORED INDIGENT NON CITIZEN.
NON CITIZENS OF TERMINA TO BE
INDIGENT IF A COUNTY DETERMINES.
THEY WOULD GO HUNGRY AND
HOMELESS WITHOUT AID.
THIS CHANGE WILL MORE CLOSELY
ALIGNED CAL ORKS ELIGIBILITY
RENEW ALL PROVISIONS WITH THOSE.
USED FOR CALIFORNIA.
WITH ME TODAY IS THE POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH ALAMEDA COUNTY
SOCIAL SERVICES.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JUST GIVE OUR FLOW
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY WE ARE A CO SPONSOR
WITH ALAMEDA COUNTY UP FOR THIS
PROPOSAL -- WE WANT TO POINT OUT
THOUGH -- THAT ADMINISTRATION
HAS HAD THE THE OPTION OF BEING
ABLE TO DO THIS FOR A LONG TIME
BUT THROUGH MANY YEARS OF
CONCERTED ADMINISTRATIVE
ADVOCACY WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
ENCOURAGE THEM. TO DO IT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS ALLOWED UNDER
FEDERAL LAW AND WE DO TAKE THIS
OPTION AND SNAP AND OF WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL TO ADOPT THE SAME
PROVISION IN OUR CALPERS PROGRAM.
OUT WITH THAT WE ARE DR.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THAT CHAIR
ORDER THAT THOUGH AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M MY NAME IS DANNY
SABBAH SO KOBE ACTUALLY ADDED.
I AM THE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
ALAMEDA COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICES.
WE ARE HONORED HERE TO BE CLOSE
TO WORK CLOSELY WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY.
AND THE COALITION OF CALIFORNIA
WELFARE RIGHTS ORGANIZATION ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
ALAMEDA COUNTY IS HERE FOR ALL
THE REASONS THAT WERE STATED BY
JESSICA BARTH HELLO.
I'M HERE TO FOCUS ON THE DATA
AND A STATEMENT FROM AN ALAMEDA
COUNTY CLIENT.
AS OF MARCH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN IN ALAMEDA COUNTY WE
ASSISTED THIRTY EIGHT
INDIVIDUALS TO RECEIVE THIS
BENEFIT. TO GET A GENERAL SENSE
OF THE IMPACT OF POPULATION WE
REACHED OUT TO CAL WHEN COUNTIES
FOR DATA FOR FISCAL YEAR.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN EMUS RESPONSE
WE RECEIVED INFORMATION FOR THE
FOLLOWING COUNTIES. FOR FRESNO.
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE SAN
FRANCISCO.
A HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
SACRAMENTO. FIFTY TWO BEEN TARA
[inaudible]
FORTY SIX HELLO LARRY. THIRTY
SIX SANTA CLARA. THIRTY FOUR
SANTA BARBARA.
TWENTY EIGHT RIVERSIDE TWENTY
AND SAN MATTEO.
TWELVE WHILE SMALL IN NUMBER IT
WOULD HELP OUR COMMUNITY
TREMENDOUSLY.
I WILL NOW READ INTO THE RECORD
TESTIMONY FROM AN ALAMEDA COUNTY
CLIENT WHO WAS HESITANT TO COME
FORWARD OUT OF FEAR OF THE
GOVERNMENT BUT WANTED TO SHARE
HIS STORY.
ON NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN I CAME WITH MY WIFE AND
YOUNG SON TO THE UNITED STATES
FROM AFGHANISTAN ON AN IMMIGRANT
VISA UNDER THE SPONSORSHIP OF MY
SISTER.
MY WIFE HAD A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME ADJUSTING TO LIFE IN THE
UNITED STATES AND AS A RESULT
SHE BECAME SEVERELY ILL.
IN MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
pMY SISTER WAS STRAINED SHE NO
LONGER WANTED TO BE INVOLVED
WITH US.
AND SHE REFUSED TO PROVIDE ANY
MONETARY SUPPORT.
LACKING RESOURCES IN JANUARY TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE APPLIED FOR
CAO WORKS AND WE'RE APPROVED
UNDER THE SPONSOREDNON CITIZEN
INDIGENT EXCEPTION.
HOWEVER ON DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AFTER BEING ON AID FOR
TWELVE MONTHS WE LOST
ELIGIBILITY DUE TO THE TWELVE
MONTH LIFETIME WRONG.
I'VE BEEN STRUGGLING TO MAINTAIN
A JOB DUE TO MY WIFE'S ILLNESS
AND INSTABILITY.
WE ARE NOW IN DANGER OF LOSING
OUR LOW INCOME HOUSING BECAUSE
WE CANNOT PAY THE RENT WITHOUT
THE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
OUR CAL WORKS GRANT PROVIDED.
PROPOSALS LIKE THIS ONE WOULD
ENABLE US TO CONTINUE GETTING
CAL WORKS AND KEEP US FROM
LOSING OUR HOUSING AND OUR
LIFELINE.
I PLEAD TO YOU THAT THIS BILL BE
PASSED INTO LAW.
IN CLOSING AS AN AGENCY WE
BELIEVE THAT NO HUMAN SHOULD
HAVE TO FACE THE POSSIBILITY OF
GOING HOMELESS.
OR HUNGRY INCLUDING IMMIGRANTS
PLEASE PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
SUPPORT IN ADVANCE.
Q. I DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE SPELL PLEASE COME
UP STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY SAID EARLY MADONNA WITH
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DEEP IMPACT NEWS
OF THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CHECK OF REGULAR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT -- MICHAEL RATIGAN ABOVE
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
WHEN THE ONE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT?
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THE NINE OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM.
THE BILL [inaudible]
ALRIGHT [inaudible]
I'M.
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THAT'S NOT NEEDED OKAY.
ALRIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION --
TO I DO PASSED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
AND A SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
A TITLE I DON'T KNOW I STONE.
BELL.
BELL I JACKSON.
PAN ALL RIGHT CAN I WIENER
[inaudible] THREE THE VOTE
THREE ZERO RIGHT NOW AND WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND HOLD THIS BILL OPEN
TO ALLOW THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
OKAY UP NEXT WE HAVE -- A. B.
FOUR SIX FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN FEEL FREE TO COME ON UP
AND PRESENT YOUR BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS VERY HONORED
TO BE HERE TODAY WITH.
TWO SIMPLE LITTLE CLEAN UP BILLS
AS WE FOLLOW WE TAKE ON AN ISSUE
AND THEN AS A BOTH.
OF THE CENTER SITTING UP HERE
BEEN HERE FOR NO THAT WE
CONTINUE TO FOLLOW THEM TO MAKE
SURE THEY'RE IMPLEMENTED AND AND
HAVE THE SPIRIT OF WHAT WE
INITIALLY INTENDED.
SO FIRST I'LL START WITH A. B..
FOR SIXTY FIVE AND THIS BILL
WILL CODIFY UNIVERSAL
DEFINITIONS IN ORDER TO JUSTIFY
OR TO IDENTIFY YOUTH IN BOTH
TRIAL WELFARE SYSTEMS IN
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEMS -- I
DID A BILL A COUPLE YEARS AGO TO
SEE HOW HOW ARE WE DEALING WITH --
DUAL STATUS YOUTH USED TO FIND
THEMSELVES BOTH IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AS WELL AS AS CHAU
WELFARE SYSTEM.
AND SO WE FOUND OUT WE DON'T DO
A GREAT JOB TRACKING THOSE YOU
THEM WHAT HAPPENS TO MORE THAN
WHERE THEY GO SO WE ASK FOR AN
AUDIT.
THAT ALREADY CAME BACK WITH A
LOT OF RECOMMENDATIONS BUT ONE
OF THE ONES THAT WE THOUGHT WE
COULD JUST START WITH WHICH TO
DEVELOP SOME UNIVERSAL
DEFINITIONS OF THE WORDS THAT WE
USE WHEN WE REFER TO YOUTH.
SO IT'S SIMPLY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS CODIFY UNIVERSAL
DEFINITIONS OF HOW WE REFER TO
USE AND USE OF LANGUAGE AROUND
YOUTHS IN THAT ARE STILL STATUS
AND BOTH.
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
THE TROUBLE FOR SYSTEM.
AND I'M OPEN TO YOUR QUESTIONS
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE PASSAGE
OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPELL.
PLEASE COME UP STAGE NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
IS STEPHANIE IRA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LINES OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES IN SUPPORT.
CHECK OF REGULAR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
COVERAGE AFTER INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
WESLEY SAVER JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH STROKES.
FOR ANDY LEVON BOMB FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THE BILL IS
UNFORTUNATELY OUTSIDE OUR
PURVIEW WE CAN'T TAKE A FIRM
POSITION BUT WE ARE SUPER
GRATEFUL THAT IT'S MOVING
FORWARD.
CRISTINA PARKER CALIFORNIA
CONNECTION IS STRONG SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE'S IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
GREAT DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE BILL ALL RIGHT.
TO PLEASE FEEL FREE TO CLOSE.
BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO
REPRESENTING MY NEXT ONE AFTER
THAT BECAUSE OF PASSAGE OF THIS.
ONE CONTINUE TO ACHIEVE JUSTICE
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION AT TO
DO PASSED SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE BY SENATOR PAN.
A SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
BUT HOW DO I AYE STONE.
BELL.
BELT AYE JACKSON PAN.
AND I WINNER.
WIENER AYE. FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND LEAVE THIS
OPEN.
OKAY.
AND THEN AB SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
IS ALSO A FOLLOW UP CLEAN UP
FROM SOME WORK I'VE DONE -- IN
THE PAST AND I'M YES I'M PROUD
TO SAY THIS YEAR I HAVE
SOMETHING ADDRESSING -- JUSTICE
ISSUES AND AND DIGNITY ISSUES
AROUND BABIES.
TEENAGERS AND NOW THIS WHEN
DEALING WITH SENIORS -- SO A
COUPLE YEARS AFTER SOME OF THE
OUTRAGEOUS THINGS WE SAW IN THE
BAY AREA -- ABOUT WITH
RESIDENTIAL SCHOOL FACILITIES OF
PEOPLE LEAVING CHARGES AND NOT
BEING LICENSE CLOSING ONE
FACILITY IN AN OPENING ANOTHER --
ONE A LOT OF LIKE HIDE THE BALL
IT FELT LIKE SOME OF THE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE DID TO TRY TO
CLEAN THAT UP WAS TO SAY.
WE HAD AB POSTED ON THE AGENCY'S
WEBSITE WHAT ANY COMPLAINTS WERE
READ OWN SOMETHING BEFORE AND
THEN IF YOU DON'T WE'RE GONNA
TRANSFERRED TO SOMETHING ELSE WE
MADE ALL THAT INFORMATION A LOT
EASIER FOR FAMILIES TO USE.
YOUR FAMILY AT HOME TRYING TO
FIND A PLACE YOU'RE GONNA PUT
YOUR LOVED ONE ALRIGHT ALREADY
HAD REALLY DIFFICULT DECISION
BUT THEN HOW DO YOU FIND OUT IF
IT'S A GOOD FACILITY OR THEY'VE
HAD ISSUES BEFORE.
SO WE CLEAN THAT UP THAT WAS IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND THIS
YEAR WE'RE COMING BACK -- JUST
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE COULD GET
TRICKY WITH THE LLC'S -- AND
MAKING A CORPORATION SAID THEIR
NAME IS NOT THERE SO THIS JUST
ALLOWS -- THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO BE ABLE.
TO LOOK MORE CLOSELY AT THE
ARRANGEMENT.
OF THE OWNERSHIP OF THESE
FACILITIES.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MY NAME
IS TONY CHICKEN TELLING THE
STAFF ATTORNEYWITH CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM.
WERE A SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN AS THE MEMBER
MENTIONED -- FOUR YEARS AGO --
SHE PASSED SB SIX A ONE THAT
DEALT WITH MORE TRANSPARENCY
RELATED TO THE OWNERSHIP OF
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY.
AND AND THAT'S BEEN VERY GOOD WE
WE THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES IS NOW GETTING.
A LIST OF OWNERSHIP RELATED TO
EACH FACILITY.
WHO HAVE UP 210% OWNERSHIP
INTEREST?
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
OF LAST SEVERAL YEARS IS THAT A
LOT OF TIMES THESE LISTS.
COMPRISE ARE COMPRISED ENTIRELY
OF ENTITIES AND WE DON'T KNOW
WHO THE INDIVIDUALS ARE BEHIND
THESE ENTITIES SO WE'VE BEEN
REALLY BLOCKED FROM THIS VERY
CORE FUNCTION OF THE STATE
GOVERNMENT WHICH IS.
MAKING SURE THAT THESE PROVIDERS
ARE GOING TO BE FIT AND
COMPETENT TO DO THIS JOB.
AND THEY'VE REALLY BEEN ABLE TO
NOT ONLY LIMIT THEIR LIABILITY
THROUGH THIS LOC ARRANGEMENT BUT
TO LIMIT THEIR IDENTITY.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIX IN THIS BILL IS TO GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT THE ABILITY TO TO
OBTAIN MORE INFORMATION RELATED
TO THE OWNERSHIP OF THESE
FACILITIES.
AND PEEL THE PAN THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO THE LICENSE SO
THAT THEY CAN BE MORE SURE THAT
THE CARE THERE'S GOING TO BE
GOOD FOR OUR SENIORS AND
DEPENDENT ADULTS.
SO.
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
PLEASE COME UP STATE YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON HEATHER
HARRISON WITH A CALIFORNIA
ASSISTED LIVING ASSOCIATION WE
ARE OFFICIALLY NEUTRAL BUT I
WANTED TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THAT TECHNICAL AMENDMENT THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LISA COLEMAN WITH
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
A QUESTION. FOR THE BILL ALL
RIGHT -- YOU WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
TIME IN THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
THEIR ANALYSIS AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE TO PROTECT THE LIVES
OF OUR SENIOR INDEPENDENT ADULTS.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION OF DO -- TO
PASS -- DO AS AMENDED PASSED TO
THE SENATE.
FOR A BY SENATOR PAN.
OUT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB FIFTY SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
EGGMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED -- OR TITLE.
HI GRETA AYE STONE.
BELL.
BELL AYE JACKSON.
PAN RIGHT PAN AYE WIENER AYE
WIENER AYE.
WELL IT'S FOUR ZERO WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND LEAVE THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A LITTLE BIT.
UP NEXT WE HAVE AB SEVEN TWO
EIGHT FIVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SANTIAGO.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME UP AND
PRESENT YOUR WHATEVER YOU
ALREADY MANAGER AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
A PRETTY PLAIN SIMPLE AB --
SEVEN TWENTY AIDS EXTENSION OF
OUR PREVIOUS WORK.
OUT WHAT IT REALLY ALLOWS US TO
DO IS -- BE ABLE TO COORDINATE I
INFORMATION RESOURCES BEFORE
PERSON FALLS IN THE HOMELESSNESS
BIKE -- BY EXTRAPOLATION MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAMS WE HAD DONE
THIS ON THE BACK AND ONE
SOMEBODY WAS HOMELESS A COUPLE
YEARS AGO THROUGH A. B. -- TO
TEN BUT WHAT WE FOUND REALLY
IMPORTANT IS THE CAPTURE THE
PERSON BEFORE THE FALL IN THE
HOMELESSNESS IN BE ABLE TO HAVE
THESE MULTI PLUS DISCIPLINARY
TEAM SHARE INFORMATION ABOUT AN
INDIVIDUAL -- SO THEY HERE SHE
MAY BE PREVENTED FROM BEING
HOMELESS I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HARD WORKING FOR ACCEPTING
THE PREVIOUS COMMITTEE AND
MAINTENANCE -- IN THIS COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AND CONSULTANTS MIGHT
THE GUERRERO REPRESENTED LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE SPONSOR OF AB
SEVEN TO EIGHT WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO FOR
CAMPING NEED THIS POLICY ISSUE
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS -- AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO -- HAS
PROVIDE THE BACKGROUND IT BUILDS
MAINTAINS THE PROTECTIONS IN THE
PRIVACY OF THE INDIVIDUALS BY
ALLOWING THEM TO OPT OUT -- ONCE
THEY'RE IN CONTACT AND THE
SEARCH THE INFORMATION WILL BE
SHARED -- FOR THE PURPOSE OF
PROVIDING -- HOUSING AND
IDENTIFYING THOSE THAT WE CAN
PREVENT TO BECOME HOMELESS --
SINCE IT IS A PILOT PROGRAM FOR
FIVE YEARS WE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING WHAT ELSE WE CAN DO AND
IT'S BEEN LIMITED DOWN TO SIX
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNTIES.
I'M AT THE REQUEST OF THIS OF
THE MEMBER CHAU -- THE NEED FOR
PREVENTING INDIVIDUALS FROM
FALLING INTO HOMELESSNESS HAS
NEVER BEEN GREATER AT THIS POINT
SINCE LOS ANGELES COUNTY HAS
EXPERIENCED A 12% INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS.
AND A NUMBER A MAJORITY OF THEM
ARE AS A RESULT OF THEM FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
SUPPORT -- IS THIS BILL HAS BEEN
UNANIMOUSLY -- SUPPORTED IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND DRIVABLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT PLEASE
COME UP STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION.
THE MEASURE ONE KEITH ON HER
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WE SO APPRECIATE
THIS AUTHOR'S EFFORTS TO HELP
COMBAT THE HOMELESSNESS ISSUE
WITHIN THIS IS ANOTHER TOOL
IMPORTANT TO THEIR COMMUNITIES.
KEEP PEOPLE FROM INJURY AND
HOMELESSNESS.
WE APPRECIATE IT WOULD ASK FOR
SUPPORT.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
CHECK OF RECORD NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
COOLEY DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
KATHY NEARLY MADONNA WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
HAVE ANY ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT -- MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL RIGHT
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY -- WE HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTING THIS BILL -- WHICH
RECENTLY MADE AWARE OF THE
AMENDMENTS LIMITING IT TO THE
SIX SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
AND WE'D LIKE TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL BUT IT.
WOULD REQUESTED A MAN MAD AT A
PLACE ONE COUNTY FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES AS
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
NOW DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CENTER PAN.
SO I I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND AS
TO AND YOUR I THINK ALL OF US
REPRESENT NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES THAT STRUGGLES
HOMELESSNESS AS WELL.
WHAT WAS THE RATIONALE FOR
LIMITING THE COUNTIES JUST TO
THE? SIX THEIR HERE WHICH I MEAN
WAS I I DON'T SEE THE CONTENDERS
IN WHAT THE CONCERN WAS AT FIRST
I WANT THANK YOU FOR YOUR BILL
IT'S AND I THINK THE IDEA OF
DOING PREVENTION AND GETTING
AHEAD OF THE CURVE.
SAID WAIT TILL SO FALLS OFF THE
CLIFF IS REALLY IMPORTANT ONE
NOW I GUESS THE QUESTION IS WHY
CAN'T WE AVAIL OURSELVES OF THIS
AS WELL.
LOONEY CERVANTES OF THE THE
PREVIOUS COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
THAT WE NARROWED DOWN TO SEE IF
IF IT'LL WORK IN THERE WAS SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT AROUND THE ISSUE
OF PRIVACY -- ORIGINALLY WE
STARTED WITH THE ENTIRE STATE
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THIS IS A
STATE WIDE PROBLEM -- IF IT'S UP
TO ME -- I'D RATHER MAKE IT
STATE WIDE -- BUT WE HAD TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATIONS.
DO DO DO EAT EGGS YOU COULD YOU
ELABORATE PERHAPS THEY KNOW THAT
YOU'RE NOT COMMITTEE YOU WERE
YOU HAD ACCEPT THESE AMENDMENTS
THAT WATER CHOICE BUT AT ONCE A
PRIVACY ISSUES I MEAN WAS THERE
SOMETHING ABOUT NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES ARE CENTRAL
VALLEY COUNTIES THAT.
WE WERE AT THAT THE COURT WE
WERE PRETTY GOOD HAILING PRIVACY.
MAY I RESPOND.
YEAH THE ISSUE WHAT THE ISSUE
WAS AND THAT OTHER COUNTIES
COULDN'T ON DEPRIVED CITY SHE
WAS ENSURING THAT WE WOULD DO --
PRIVACY CORRECTLY AND THAT IT
WOULDN'T BE.
BUT THERE WOULDN'T BE ANY ISSUES
WITH THAT I I I THINK THAT WAS
EXACTLY WAS TOLD US.
A BOOK I'D BE HAPPY CHANGE I
CAN'T CHANGE SHOULD BE --
BECAUSE THE PREVIOUS COMMITTEE
HAD SUGGESTED THAT IDEA BUT I'D
BE OPEN AND WILLING TO WORK WITH
YOU TO GET IT CHANGED ABSOLUTELY
I'D HAVE TO HAVE THE MIND OF THE
PREVIOUS CAMINO.
SURE OKAY -- I UNDERSTAND YOUR
DILEMMA -- I HOPE PERHAPS WE CAN
RAISE THE QUESTION THAT WE WOULD
GIVE ACTUALLY COUNTIES THE
OPTION.
THAT YOU KNOW -- STUDENTS TO TO
TO DO THIS IF THEY WISHED I
THINK THAT WOULD BE YEAH COUNTY
DOESN'T THAT'S FINE -- BUT I
HOPE THAT WE CAN.
MAYBE MOVE TO A PLACE WHERE.
COUNTIES COULD IF THEY CHOSE TO
DO SO SELECT TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS ADD MORE IN LINE WITH YOUR
ORIGINAL BILL AND CERTAINLY --
THE BIKE THINK ABOUT HOW WE
COULD WORK WITH YOU AND THE
ASSEMBLY PRIZE COMMITTEE -- TO
TO BE SURE THAT IF THERE WERE
SPECIFIC PRIVACY CONCERNS THEY
HAD ABOUT OTHER COUNTIES COMING
ABOARD THAT WE GET THIS
ADDRESSED BUT TO GET TO A PLACE
WHERE.
COUNTIES IF THEY CHOOSE TO DO SO.
WOULD BE ABLE -- TO AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF OF OF OF YOUR BILL
[inaudible]
IN.
MADAM CHAIR MY RESPOND.
YEAH SIR.
YEAH WE DID A PREVIOUS BILL
WHERE THAT ONE WAS STATE WIDE IF
IF MY MEMORY SERVES IN LOAN THAT
WAS AB TWO TEN AND THAT SEEMS TO
BE GO IT WILL BE GOING IN
IMPLEMENTATION.
BUT BUT AT THE SAME TIME I WOULD
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH YOU THAT
THAT IS THAT I WOULD THINK IT'S
A STATEWIDE -- CONCERN AND THE
REASON IT WAS NEAR THOSE
PARTICULAR COUNTIES IS BECAUSE
WE WERE ABLE TO SUSTAIN MORE
THAN JUST LA COUNTY BY SAYING
THAT IT'S A REGIONAL.
ISSUE OTHERWISE I THINK YOU MAY
BE BEEN BEEN TAPERED A LITTLE
BIT -- MORE NARROW -- BUT
CERTAINLY I THINK THERE'S A
SPIRIT OF ON SHARING INFORMATION
THAT WOULD EXTEND FROM THE FIRST
BILL THAT WE DID -- WHICH
ALLOWED THE SHARING OF
INFORMATION -- ONE SOMEBODY WAS
HOMELESS AND LET ME.
WALK YOU THROUGH JUST TO REFRESH
YOUR MEMORY BUT IF SOMEBODY --
WAS HOMELESS IN THE VISITED --
LET'S A PROBATION OFFICER OR OR
OR SOMEBODY IN CAL WORKS
ETCETERA THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL
CAN THEN SHARE THE INFORMATION --
OF THE RECIPIENT OF SERVICES
WITH ANOTHER COUNTY OR NONPROFIT
AGENCY OR CITY TO TRY TO GET
THAT PERSON AND THE USER --
SUPPORT SERVICES IT BASICALLY
THING CONCEPT I I WOULD I WOULD
AGREE WITH YOU BUT AND I WOULD --
I WOULD HELP THOSE ARGUMENTS TO
INCLUDE OTHER COUNTIES.
IT GOES OFF THANK YOU AGAIN I
RECOGNIZE IT'S A VALID THANK YOU
FOR THE BILL AND I RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS IS NOT EXACT AND
SITUACIóN YOUR OWN CHOOSING
[inaudible]
I'VE.
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE
[inaudible]
I THOUGHT.
WELL I'M I'M CONFUSED NOW
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE WHERE ON THE
BILL IT.
IS LIMITED.
RAPPER.
AND I DIDN'T SEE AN ANALYSIS
THAT DOESN'T SAID THE PRIVACY
COMMITTEE HEARD THE BILL.
IT SAYS ONLY EARNED SERVICES.
I THANK I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
PROCESS OF MATHEMATICAL.
YEAH IT'S IT'S IT'S MINOR SO YOU
CAN -- YOU CAN -- PRACTICE OF
AMONG OTHER WAS A TECHNICAL AIR
WHIRLS NOT LIMITED AND SO THOSE
AMENDMENTS HAD TO BE TAKEN AND
THIS COMMITTEE -- BUT THAT IT
WAS RECOMMENDED TO ME IN AND THE
PREVIOUS CONTRACT.
THAT'S CORRECT THERE WAS A FOR
IT WAS DOUBLE REFERRED IN THE
ASSEMBLY IT WAS HUMAN SERVICES
PROSSER OKAY I THINK THERE'S A
TECHNICAL ERROR WITH THAT THAT'S
WHAT WORKS UP IN THE THE CAN I
THINK WHAT'S UP IN THE
AMENDMENTS IN THIS COMMITTEE.
THAT WERE THAT WERE -- FOR ASKED
OF ME TO ACCEPT IN THE PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE. FOR THE PRIVACY
COMMITTEE.
HAD AMENDMENTS THAT WERE NEVER
TAKEN ANY ASSEMBLY ACCEPTED THEM --
THEM AS A MINUTE TECHNICAL AREA
WHERE THEY WEREN'T WRITTEN IN
AND SO I HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
ACCEPT THEM HERE OF COURSE
[inaudible]
THE WERE REQUIRED.
YOU OFFER THE YOU CAN REJECT.
I KNOW I MEAN I HAVE I HAVE.
TO ACCEPT THEM.
JUST FOR CLARIFICATION.
AND SPEAKING WITH OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF THEY'RE LETTING ME KNOW
THAT THEY DID GO THROUGH --
PRIVACY RIGHT THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE FOR FOR SOME REASON
BUT IT DOESN'T SHOW UP IN THE
ANALYSIS PART OF THE TECHNICAL
VOTED.
IT WASN'T JUST A INFORMED ON THE
BODICE I CAN [inaudible]
PRIVACY.
YEAH -- INTO WHETHER THERE ARE
TO PASS AS AMENDED.
OKAY THEY HAD A VOTER APPROACH
[inaudible]
THE BILL.
I CAN I HAVE A HARD TIME VOTING
ON AMENDMENTS THAT PUT MY COUNTY
OUT OF THE PROGRAM.
KIND OF LIFE THE LIMO SO I WOULD
ASK THE LEAST MASON I CAN'T I
CAN'T.
I MEAN.
I GOT A LITTLE DILEMMA HERE
[inaudible]
WILL.
I I CAN UNDERSTAND YOUR DILEMMA
ASYOU AS I'M SURE YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND MINE -- I WOULD JUST
LOOK AT WE KEEP MOVING THIS
FORWARD AND I'D BE HAPPY TO SIT
IN ADVOCATE FOR YOUR COUNTY AS
WELL I JUST CAN'T -- I WANT.
TO BUT I CAN'T -- I CAN'T WELL
WE'RE THE COMMITTEES.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
HOLDEN TRY TO GET SOME YEAH YEAH.
ALL RIGHT JUST OKAY WITH THAT I
MEAN IT'S BEING -- THE
REQUISITION.
DOUBLE CROSSER CAT DOUBLE
REFERRED TO CENTURY I MEAN THE
MAN TERMINATE.
I MEAN NOTHING WE CAN DO IS MOVE
IT AND I MEAN I'M HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU TO GET AN EXPANDED I
JUST HAVE TO BE ABLE TO WORK
THROUGH AND THROUGH THE PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE OKAY WITH A AS LONG AS A
DEADLINES WILL MISTER.
DEADLINES I'M OKAY WITH
[inaudible]
AND IT'S ALSO TO APPROPRIATIONS
I HAS A FISCAL DEADLINE.
SO WE CAN HOLD IT -- AND YOU
KNOW JUST WORK ON IT SOME MORE
AND GET SOME THINGS CLARIFIED
AND THIS THAT WORK FOR EVERYONE.
MY OKAY HOLD A THE BILL HERE
INTIMIDATION WORK ON IT FROM.
AND IN.
DOWN THE ROAD IT COULD HAPPEN
AND IT IS IT THE HOTEL WORKER.
SO WHERE TO JUDICIARY --
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND
APPROPRIATIONS AS WELL THE TIME
IF WE CONTINUE THERE'S NO.
RIGHT HERE ON THE WORLD.
THIS WEEK.
HELLO WEEK WHEN WE HAVE A WEEK
WINDOW.
IS THAT IS.
THAT I MEAN BECAUSE THIS ISN'T
YOUR DOING SO I DON'T WANT YOU
TO SUFFER THE ONE I'M OKAY WITH
IT AS LONG AS IT CAN GET OUT
INTO THE ON TO THE FLOOR --
COULD BE DEBATED ON THE I MEAN
THAT'S THAT'S FINE WITH ME --
BUT IF THERE IS IF IT'S NOT
GOING TO HARM THE BILL.
AND IF THERE'S A POSSIBILITY OF
EXPANDING -- THAT'S OKAY WITH ME
TOO YEAH MAN I'M HAPPY TO TALK
TO THE TO THE PREVIOUS CHAIR --
ALONG WITH YOU GUYS TO EXPAND IT
TO DIFFERENT COUNTIES I'M HAPPY
TO DO THAT MAYBE THE COMMITTEE
CAN.
ALSO THAT WOULD BE THE BEST
PLACE OUT.
A LITTLE OVER. ONE GONZALEZ
MAKES IT TO THE FLOOR ON TIME
I'M GOOD.
GOOD WITH IT I UNDERSTAND.
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH -- FOR
FOR YOUR YOU KNOW. FOR ALLOWING
THIS -- WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE ON
THIS BILL NO I AGREE I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S WORK --
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION BECAUSE IN THE
REASON I'M OKAY WITH HOLDING IT
IS BECAUSE I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORT CONVERSATION STATEWIDE I
MEAN.
ARE COUNTIES AND CITIES CAME UP
PUBLISHED 17% -- INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS -- RESPECTIVELY AND
SO WE FEEL JUST AS JUST AS
PASSIONATELY ABOUT AS ANYBODY
ELSE -- ON THIS COMMITTEE OR IN
THIS WHEN THE CAPITAL THAT WE
GOT TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT SO
IF WE CAN FIGURE OUT A BETTER
PLACE IN THE PREVIOUS COMMITTEES
OKAY WITH IT I'M I'M HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HOPEFULLY BOND THIS OUT THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS ONE MEMBER
SANTIAGO WE WILL GO AND WORK
WITH YOU -- WE JUST HOPE FOR FOR
SUCH A QUICK SECOND ABSOLUTELY
[inaudible] ONE I COLLUDED
[inaudible]
WE GO
.
US ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO OUT
THERE IS NO FURTHER ACTION
REQUIRED AT THIS MOMENT WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND SET THE BILL -- FOR
HEARING -- FOR THE TWENTY FOURTH.
WILL WORK WITH YOU IN THE
MEMBERS.
WE APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU.
NEXT -- A. B. ONE ONE THREE
SEVEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU ARE READY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I PROMISE THIS IS GOING TO BE
EASY.
A FRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO START
BY THANKING THE CHAIR AND HER
CONSULTANT ON WORKING WITH ME TO
DRAFT THE AMENDMENTS -- WHICH
ADDRESS TO SEE COLDER CONCERNS I
DO INTEND TO TAKE THESE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS -- TO
RESOLVE CONCERNS BEFORE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
AB ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN IS
DESIGNED TO UPDATE AND MODERNIZE
THE OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT TO
REFLECT CHANGING PARADIGMS IN
SERVICE DELIVERY AND TERMINOLOGY.
THE BILL ALSO DELETE OBSOLETE
STATUTES.
THAT ARE NO LONGER IN EFFECT IN
PARTICULAR -- THE THE MEASURE
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING
TO PROVIDE AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING WITH THE FLEXIBILITY TO
DEVELOP AND MANAGE.
PROGRAMS BASED ON LOCAL NEEDS
THIS WOULD HAPPEN THROUGH BLOCK
GRANTING OF FUNDS FOR VARIOUS
PROGRAMS SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
THE LEGISLATURE HAS AMENDED THE
OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT.
SEVERAL TIMES TO REFLECT THE
CHANGING POPULATION AND EMERGING
SERVICE DELIVERY NEEDS DESPITE
THESE AMENDMENTS THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT STILL CONTAINS
SEVERAL OUTDATED SECTIONS.
WITH LANGUAGE THAT NEEDS
UPDATING TO REFLECT THE CHANGING
TIMES THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP TO ENSURE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAWS.
KEEP UP WITH THE NEEDS OF OUR
AGING POPULATION -- WITH ME IN
SUPPORT IS -- ARE.
AT THEIR HOTEL FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING AND LISA
COLEMAN FROM THE CALIFORNIA LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION.
YES MADAM CHAIR GIRL COACH WITH
THE HAIR AGENCIES ON AGING.
IT'S BEEN NEARLY FORTY YEARS
SINCE THIS ACT WAS CREATED.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT MANY OF
THE STATUE TURNOUT DATED.
A INCONSISTENT WITH WHERE.
WE ARE TRYING TO MOVE THE
DELIVERY SYSTEM TODAY.
AND SO WE THINK THAT IT'S TIME.
TO TO ELIMINATE SOME OF THE OUT
DATED STATUTES AND TO LOOK FOR
THE FUTURE.
SO -- WE ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER
THIS.
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR IRA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR OF MY
NAME IS LISA BUT I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION A
MEMBERSHIP ASSOCIATION MADE UP
OF THE LOCAL LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM STAFF
VOLUNTEERS AND PROGRAM
SUPPORTERS.
WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF ELEVEN OF THIRTY
SEVEN THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF AGING IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE OLDER
AMERICANSACT PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ONE OF
THOSE IS THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM.
AND WHILE THERE ARE MANY THINGS
TO BE SUPPORTIVE ABOUT AB ELEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN I'M GONNA USE MY
AND ONE MINUTE. TO FOCUS ON THE
COST CONTAINMENT ASPECT OF THE
BILL.
THE CURRENT W. AN AYE CODE I'D
NINETY ONE HUNDRED STIPULATES
THAT CDA SHALL CONSIDER
AVAILABLE DATA POPULATION TRENDS
IN DEVELOPING PROGRAMS AND
POLICIES.
AND YET THE DEPARTMENT IS
RESTRICTED IN DEVELOPING AND
SUPPORTING INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS
FOR OLDER ADULTS IF TO DO SO
EXCEEDS THE CURRENT FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS FOR THESE PROGRAMS.
EVERY FOUR YEARS THE DEPARTMENT
SPENDS MUCH TIME AND RESOURCES
IN THE CRAFTING OF CD A STATE
PLAN ON AGING.
THIS REPORT SPECIFIES CTA'S
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES FOR
PLANNING. FOR THE PLANNING
PERIOD IS DEFINED.
WITH ARTICULATED ACTIVITIES FOR
THE STATE OLDER CALIFORNIA
PROGRAMS.
THE CURRENT PROGRAM FROM TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO INCLUDES DATA.
PAGES AND PAGES OF DATA
HIGHLIGHTING OF POPULATION
TRENDS FOR CASTING CURRENT AND
GROWING NEEDS FOR SERVICES.
AND YET THIS VERY IMPORTANT
REPORT IS DIMINISHED IN VALUE
BECAUSE THE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
RESTRICTED TO PROGRAM GOALS
OBJECTIVES AND STRATEGIES THAT
CAN BE CHEAP ACHIEVED WITHIN
CTA'S EXISTING MEANS.
THE CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION IS PLEASED
TO SUPPORT AND WE THANK MEMBER
AND ASSYRIAN FOR AUTHORING THIS
I NEEDED LEGISLATION.
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING THE-AUTHORITY TO IDENTIFY AND
PROMOTE SYSTEMS OF DEVELOPMENT.
THAT WILL ENSURE A BETTER LIFE
FOR OLDER INDEPENDENT ADULTS
WITH ADEQUATE SERVICE PROGRAMS.
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
COME UP STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION.
SHARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS SPLIT
JOHNSON WHO ABOUT FEATURES A FEW
ALTAMONT IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU MISTER BEAVIS SAID THE ARIAN.
OR THE SHIP IN THE PORT ISSUE.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
NOW OKAY TO HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
KERN [inaudible] FIVE WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE
THE BILL TO PASS TO AND THE
MOTION IS TO DO PASSED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
US SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
RICARDO I RICARDO EYES STONE DEL.
VALLE I JACKSON PAN.
PAN AYE WIENER.
WIENER I WAS.
ZERO THE VOTE WAS FOUR ZERO WILL
GO AHEAD AND LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN.
MANY OF THE JEWS.
ALL.
RIGHT.
AND WE ALSO HAVE -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NAZARIAN HERE TO PRESENT
AB ONE TWO THREE FIVE ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER TIãU.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU ARE READY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR A WAS GIVEN THE WONDERFUL
TASK OF A PRESENTING THIS AB
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE
KANSEN CHU WHO COULDN'T BE HERE
UNFORTUNATELY -- A. B. TWELVE
THIRTY FIVE BASICALLY MAKES
THREE CHANGES TO THE WELFARE AND
INSTITUTIONS CODE FIRST.
IT CHANGES THE NAME RUN AWAY AND
HOMELESS YOUTH SHELTERS TO YOUTH
HOMELESS HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION
CENTERS.
THE NAME CHANGE MADE AT THE
REQUEST OF THE SHELTERS WOULD
MORE ACCURATELY REFLECT.
THE WORK THE TWO AND A
POPULATION THAT THEY SERVE.
THE SECOND CHANGE EXPANDS THE
CATEGORIES OF YOUTH WHO CAN BE
HELPED BY YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION CENTERS.
FINALLY A. B. TWELVE THIRTY FIVE
INCREASES THE AMOUNT OF TIME A
YOUTH CAN STAY.
AT ONE OF THESE FACILITIES FROM
TWENTY ONE TEN NINETY NINE IN
ORDER TO HAVE THEIR NEEDS MET.
THIS IS CRITICAL BECAUSE
APPROXIMATELY 25% OF YOUTH WHO
RECEIVED TEMPORARY SHELTER NEED
MORE THAN TWENTY ONE NIGHTS TO
RESOLVE THEIR CASES.
THE CURRENT TWENTY ONE NIGHT
RULE IS BECAUSE FEDERAL FUNDING
CAN BE USED TO SHELTER YOUTH.
FOR A MAXIMUM OF TWENTY ONE
NIGHTS AB TWELVE THIRTY FIVE
ALLOWS OTHER FUNDING SOURCES TO
BE USED FOR LONGER STAYS.
NOW IF THE YOUTH NEEDS SHELTER
BEYOND TWENTY ONE NIGHTS THE
CENTERS THIS CHARGE AND THEN WE
HAD MET.
THEM FOR ADDITIONAL TWENTY ONE
NIGHT PERIODS AT A TIME.
OF WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OUR AMANDA CLIFFORD OF
THE BILL WAS THE WILSON CENTER
AND WEST SEAVER OF JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS WESLEY SAY FROM A POLICY
ADVOCATE WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH I'M HERE TO
SPEAK TODAY AS A CO SPONSOR OF
A. B..
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NAZARIAN SHARED THE THREE
PROVISIONS OF AB TWELVE THIRTY
FIVE WILL SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE
THE OPERATION OF RUNAWAY AND
HOMELESS YOUTH SHELTERS.
IN CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE ELEVEN
RUNAWAY AND HOMELESS YOUTH
SHELTERS IN CALIFORNIA IN ON ANY
GIVEN NIGHT THIS VITAL NETWORK
CONSERVE UP TO A COMBINED ONE
HUNDRED FORTY SIX YOU.
THE SHELTERS OFFER A
COMPREHENSIVE SUITE OF SERVICES
INCLUDING HOUSING CASE
MANAGEMENT -- COUNSELLING
REFERRALS TO COMMUNITY SERVICES
LIFE SKILLS AND ACADEMIC SUPPORT.
BY RECLASSIFYING THE SHELTERS
AND EXPANDING THE CATEGORIES OF
YOU THROUGH THEY MAY SERVE AB
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE EFFECTIVELY
REMOVES BARRIERS THAT OCCURRED
DURING THE INTAKE PROCESS.
ENABLING PROVIDERS TO MORE
COMPREHENSIVELY EXPEDITIOUSLY
DELIVER CARE TO THE YOUTH TO
ARRIVE AT THEIR DOORSTEP.
AB TWELVE THIRTY FIVE ALSO
OFFERS THESE YOUTH THE PROVIDERS
MORE TIME.
UNDER CURRENT STATUTE YOUTH ME
ONLY STATE RUN AWAY HOMELESS YOU
SHELTERS FOR TWENTY ONE
CONSECUTIVE NIGHTS AND FOR THE
MORE COMPLEX CASES THIS IS AN
INSUFFICIENT SERVICE WINDOW. FOR
THESE YOUTH THE EXTENDED
PROGRAMMATIC TIME OF NINETY
CONSECUTIVE DAYS MADE POSSIBLE
BY A. B. TWELVE THIRTY FIVE IS
CRITICAL.
ALLOWS FOR STABILITY AND
INTERVENTIONS THAT MORE
ADEQUATELY MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
YOUTH IF PASSED CALIFORNIA WOULD
JOIN ILLINOIS MINNESOTA NEW YORK
BY ALLOWING YOU TO STATE THE
SHELTERS FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
ONE NIGHTS.
AB TWELVE THIRTY FIVE OFFERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THREE SMALL
BUT SMART POLICY CHANGES WHICH
WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY BE IMPACTFUL
FOR A SMALL BUT VULNERABLE YOUTH
POPULATION.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE OF
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ALSO THANK YOU TO
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF YOUR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AMANDA CLIFFORD AND I
AM THE POLICY IN ADVOCACY
ASSOCIATE FOR BILL WILSON CENTER
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE A STORY
WITH YOU ABOUT A FAMILY WHO
RECENTLY RECEIVED SERVICES AT
BILL WISON CENTER.
AT THE BEGINNING OF MAY A
MOTHER'S THREE DROPPED OFF HER
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD TWIN GIRLS AND
ELEVEN YEAR OLD BOY.
THE FAMILY COULD NOT FIND A
FAMILY SHELTER THAT WOULD TAKE
HER AND HER THREE CHILDREN SHE
CONTINUED TO LIVE IN THE CAR
WHILE HER CHILDREN WERE WITH US
AT A RUN AWAY SHELTER.
IMMEDIATELY A CASE MANAGER BEGAN
TO WORK WITH THE MOTHER TO FIND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INEXPENSIVE
MARKET OF SILICON VALLEY.
WHILE WE WORK WITH MOM TO FIND
HOUSING WE WERE ABLE TO KEEP THE
THREE CHILDREN IN SCHOOL AND ON
TRACK TO FINISH THE YEAR.
THE CHILDREN RECEIVE COUNSELING
AND SUPPORT SERVICES MOM VISITED
FREQUENTLY AND WE WORK TOGETHER.
THE GOAL OF FAMILY REUNIFICATION.
THIS PAST FRIDAY THE FAMILY WILL
BE REMOVED THIS PAST FRIDAY THE
FAMILY WAS REUNITED AND LIVING
TOGETHER IN STABLE HOUSING IF WE
WERE LIMITED TO TWENTY ONE DAYS.
THE FAMILY WOULD HAVE BEEN BACK
LIVING IN THEIR CAR HOMELESS
INSTEAD OF EASILY HOUSE IT TOOK
BILL WILSON CENTER SIX WEEKS TO
IDENTIFY STABLE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITY.
AND PREVENT FUTURE HOMELESSNESS
FOR THE ENTIRE FAMILY BY
EXPANDING THE DEFINITION OF AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS IT WOULD
ALLOW MORE SHELTERS LIKE THE
WILSON CENTER. TO TAKE USE
COMING FROM HOMELESS FAMILIES
WITHOUT HAVING TO LABEL THEM
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS -- RUN AWAY
USE IN CLOSING WE NEED TO HAVE
ENOUGH TIME TO HELP REUNITE USE
WITH THEIR FAMILIES OR FIND
OTHER STABLE LIVING SITUATION.
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE THAT FOR
ALL CHILDREN THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANYONE DISS --
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
COME UP STATE YOUR NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. SEVEN ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
CAN LAST FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH AND SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE I'VE LOOKED CALIFORNIA
LINES OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES IN SUPPORT -- MICHAEL
RADIANT ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY.
TAKE A BREAK -- NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
YEAH THESE ENTERING WITHOUT ALL
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
NOW DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CENTER PAT.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE --
SOMEONE'S AREA HERE ACTUALLY
SOMETHING -- FOR SOME -- SOME
MEMBERS -- TO I GUESS MY
QUESTION HAS TO DO WITH THE THE
FUNDING AND I KNOW WE'RE TO
POLICY ME LET FISCAL COMMITTEE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE FUNDS THAT
COME FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
FROM THE FEDERAL RUNAWAY AND
HOMELESS YOUTH ACT -- CAN ONLY
APPLY TO FOR TWENTY ONE FOR THAT
TWENTY ONE DAYS THE NONPROFIT
CENTER.
AND THEN ALICE'S DID NOT SET A
SERVICE AND CERTAIN HOW MUCH
MONEY WAS THERE.
SO I AGREE WITH YOU THAT FROM A
STRICTLY POLICY STANDPOINT
HAVING A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME
MAKES SENSE.
I I I I DID WANT TO JUST RAISE
THE ISSUE ABOUT ARE THERE
CONCERNS THAT WE'RE GONNA LOSE
CAPACITY.
SO THAT -- EVERY EVERY AT RISK
OF LOSING ANY OF OF SOME
CAPACITY.
BY A LOSS OF THOSE FEDERAL FUNDS --
BECAUSE NOW I CAN'T PRESUME THAT
THE STATE WOULD MAKE UP FOR THAT
CELL -- THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION BUT ACCORDING TO OUR
RESEARCH THIS HAS NOT COME UP IN
ANY OF THE OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE EXPANDED THEIR LENGTH OF
STAY.
SO MINNESOTA MINNESOTA NEW YORK
IN ILLINOIS' HAVE NOT
ENCOUNTERED THIS PROBLEM.
YEAH.
RIGHT THAT THAT SELF I JUST WANT
TO BE SURE OF WE ARE WALKING
INTO THIS EYES WIDE OPEN
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
HELPFULNESS OF HAVING A LONGER
TIME AND I THINK TO THE DEGREE
THAT WE CAN ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN.
THAT'S GREAT -- I JUST WANT TO
BE CAUTIOUS ABOUT NOT LOSING
CAPACITY BECAUSE OF LOS FEDERAL
FUNDING.
OF THE BILL THE BILL WILSON
CENTER IS ACTUALLY.
A ORGANIZATION IN MY AREA THAT
RUNS IS -- DAY DAY CENTERS AND A
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES. FOR MANY
DECADES AND THEY'VE DONE A GREAT
JOB.
OF ONE DAY I WENT TO THE DAY
CENTER OF BILL WILSON
[inaudible]
AND THEY WERE TAKING A TOUR OF
IT AND MAN I'M SURE A WALK BY
TOO CLOSE TO A PACK OF DOGS THAT
WERE TIED UP AND EVIDENTLY THE
YOUNG.
WOMEN THAT WERE HOMELESS.
WERE.
ALL OF THE OWNERS OF VARIOUS
DOGS.
AND I GOT A LITTLE CLOSE IN ONE
OF THE DOGS RUSHED OUT AND HIT
ME IN THE IN THE IN THE FOOT.
AT THE BILL WILSON DAYCARE
CENTER.
WHAT ABOUT THREE YEARS FOUR
YEARS LATER -- I HAD THIS -- OF
STUDENT INTERN FROM SAN JOSE
STATE -- WORK IN MY OFFICE.
AND SHE CAME UP TO ME ONE DAY
THIS IS YOU KNOW I MET YOU
BEFORE.
AND SHE WAS GETTING HER DEGREE
IN SOCIAL WORK.
AND SHE SAID.
I'M THE I'M THE YOUNG LADY THAT.
WAS THE OWNER OF THE DOG THAT
BIT YOU.
HAD THE BILL QUESTION SO -- SO
SHE ACTUALLY WENT ON BECAME A
SOCIAL WORKER AND SHE'S NOW --
HOUSE LANE CHILDREN'S AT ONE OF
THE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AND
SILICON VALLEY SO
SO A LOT OF THESE -- HOMELESS
USE -- CAN AND WOULD BE.
VERY IMPORTANT HOUSE AND I SO I
SUPPORT THIS -- NINETY DAY I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE EXTEND THIS THIS WILL ALLOW
US.
TO HAVE THAT TRANSITION THAT'S
NEEDED TO FIND THEM -- PERMANENT
HOUSING.
AND WOULD LIKE TO MAKE THE
MOTION FOR THE BILL AND AN ASSET
TO BE ADDED AS CO AUTHOR OF
ALRIGHT ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM TWENTY MEMBERS.
NOW THIS IS THE ONE WHERE THE
GIRLS.
DOG BIT ME IT WAS A HUSKY.
HELLO CAM A MEAN DOG.
OKAY SO -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
VERY TEMPTED TO KNOW WHERE THE
BITE WAS AT THIS POINT FROM MY
ANKLE.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT HEARD -- I WILL GLADLY
PASS IT ALONG TO THE TO THE
ASSEMBLYMAN THAT YOU'D LIKE TO
BE A CO AUTHOR AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTERS.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY A CENTRE
BELL.
AND THE MOTIONS TO DO AND AND
SENATOR PAN TO DO PASSED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
US SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
RICARDO I RETURNED A AYE STONE
BELL.
BELL I'D JACKSON PAN HI CAN I
AND WIENER.
WIENER I WAS A SAID ABOUT FOUR
ZERO WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
HOLD THIS BILL FROM OPEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHICH ONE ARE WE DOING.
OKAY UP NEXT AB ONE THREE TWO
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOVE.
COME ON UP.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR
WILL ENSURE THAT UNDOCUMENTED
MINORS IN CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM ARE PROVIDED WITH
ESSENTIAL IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICES.
NECESSARY TO SEEK LAWFUL
RESIDENTS IN THE UNITED STATES
IS ALREADY THE CASE FOR
UNDOCUMENTED MINORS IN THE
CUSTODY OF THE OFFICE OF REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT.
AND SO WE'RE MAKING SURETHAT
THEY HAVE THIS FOR FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER SYSTEM
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
WITH ME.
IN TO PROVIDE TESTIMONIES
ABIGAIL TROLL AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE EMBERS.
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF LEGAL
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN AND WE ARE
VERY PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THIS
BILL -- I HAVE WORKED AT LEGAL
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN FOR TWENTY
THREE YEARS AND DURING THAT TIME
I REPRESENTED MANY CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE AND IN IMMIGRATION
MATTERS AND MANY CHILDREN.
WHO CROSS INTO BOTH OF THOSE
SYSTEMS AND I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
SEE FIRSTHAND WHAT A HUGE
DIFFERENCE IT MAKES WHEN OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE IN FOSTER CARE ABLE
TO LEAVE THAT SYSTEM FULLY ABLE
TO WORK?
AND TO TRANSITION INTO ADULTHOOD
WITH THEIR DOCUMENTATION FULLY
TAKING CARE OF THIS HAS ALWAYS
BEEN AN IMPORTANT ISSUE IN ALL
OF THESE YEARS THAT I HAVE BEEN
WORKING BUT IT'S MORE WAY WAY
MORE IMPORTANT NOW WHEN WE'RE
FACING A OFTEN A HOSTILE
IMMIGRATION SERVICES AND EVEN
JUST MAKING THE DECISION. TO
APPLY FOR IMMIGRATION RELIEF IS
A RISKY ONE THAT NO FOSTER CHILD
TO GO THROUGH WITHOUT COUNSEL OF
A LICENSED ATTORNEY.
AND SO THIS BILL IS EVEN MORE
CRITICAL THIS ISSUES EVEN MORE
CRITICAL NOW THAN EVER --
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO SOMETIMES
SEE WHEN THERE IS NOT ON THE
FUNDING AND ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEM TO MAKE SURE THAT
CHILDREN ARE PROVIDED WITH THE
SERVICES WE SEE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS.
WHO I MEAN IT'S A PAY FROM OUR
SYSTEM WITHOUT LEGAL STATUS AND
THAT IS A TRAGEDY -- IT IS A
TRAGEDY BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
FOSTER YOU ALREADY HAVE MANY
SOMETHING STAKED AGAINST THEM IN
TERMS OF EMPLOYMENT HOMELESSNESS
ARE HIGH RISK FOR HOMELESS HAS
AN UNEMPLOYMENT INTO A TO TAKE
AWAY.
THE ABILITY WORK LEGALLY IS IS
IS REALLY REALLY.
A A DETRIMENTAL BLOW -- BUT
FINALLY IT'S A TRAGEDY BECAUSE
THESE ARE OUR CHILDREN THESE ARE
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER CHILDREN
THEY ARE LITERALLY IN THE CARE
OF CUSTODY OF OUR GOVERNMENT.
AND IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE EVERY
SINGLE THING THAT THEY NEED TO
EMANCIPATE AND SUCCESSFULLY
TRANSITION INTO ADULTHOOD.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPELL PLEASE COME UP STATE NAME
AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
CHECK OF RECORD NATIONAL
ASSOCIATIONS SO SHORT CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE ISLA CALIFORNIA LINES
OF CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES IN
SUPPORT.
KATHY SAID EARLY METALLICA
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THREE
NINE OKAY TO HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
THE BILL [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION SENATORS THERE'S
NO OPPOSITION THE BILL ARE STUCK
FAST FOR MY VOTE.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
PAN TO DO PASSED THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
US SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
OUR DAUGHTER HI -- TOTAL AYE
STONE BELL.
BELL I JACKSON PAN.
PAN AYE WIENER [inaudible] THREE
ZERO SO WE HAVE A THREE ZERO
LOCAL HAD AN AWFUL.
THANK YOU SENATORS I'LL SAVE MY
DOG BITES STORY FOR ANOTHER TIME
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU [inaudible]
SO.
SO UP NEXT WE HAVE -- ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE THREE THREE SIX BY
SOMEONE MEMBERS.
PLEASE COME ON UP AND FEEL FREE
TO START WHEN YOU ARE READY
[inaudible]
I'M.
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO SECURE
WITNESSES MAY TAKE UP TO THREE
MINUTES FOR THEIR TESTIMONY AND
FOR THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH EACH YEAR
IN CALIFORNIA NEARLY ONE
THOUSAND CHILDREN DIE.
ANOTHER TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND ARE
HOSPITALIZED WITH SEVERE
INJURIES AND FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR SEEN IN EMERGENCY
ROOMS DUE TO PREVENTABLE
UNINTENTIONAL INJURIES.
IN ADDITION TO THE HEARTBREAK OF
THE INJURY OR DEATH OF A CHILD
THE COST TO CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
IS ESTIMATED AT MORE THAN ONE
MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
MILLION A YEAR.
INITIAL HEALTHCARE COSTS AND
THREE POINT FOUR BILLION IN
ONGOING MEDICAL AND WAGE LOSS
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THESE
PREVENTABLE INJURIES.
KIDS PLATES ARE ANY PERSONALIZED
LICENSE PLATE WITH A STAR
HANDPRINT PLUS SIGN OR HEART
SHAPED.
PART OF THE KIDS PLATES REVENUE
FUNDS FOR CHILDHOOD
UNINTENTIONAL INJURY PREVENTION
PROGRAMS AT THE LOCAL AND
STATEWIDE EXCUSE ME AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND STATEWIDE.
THE LIST OF CHILDHOOD INJURY
ISSUES HAS NOT BEEN UPDATED
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY TWO TO
REFLECT ALL OF THE EIGHT LEADING
CAUSES OF CHILDHOOD
UNINTENTIONAL INJURY ISSUES.
AB THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX ADDS THE
MISSING LEADING CAUSES OF
UNINTENTIONAL INJURIES RESULTING
IN THE HIGHEST FREQUENCY OF
CHILDHOOD DEATHS AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN AND YOUTH
THROUGH THE AGE.
NINETEEN THESE INCLUDE
UNINTENTIONAL INJURIES INVOLVING
VEHICLE BICYCLE AND PEDESTRIAN
CRASHES.
POISONING BURNS SUDDEN INFANT
DEATH SYNDROME OR SIDS.
DROWNING WINDOW FALLS KIDS LEFT
IN CARS OR BEING BACKED OVER IN
DRIVEWAYS AND PARKING LOTS AND
SPORTS RELATED INJURIES.
AB THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX WILL
ENSURE THAT FUNDING CAN BE
CONCENTRATED AND DIRECTED TOWARD
THE MOST CRITICAL NEEDS FOR
KEEPING OUR CHILDREN SAFE.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY WITNESSES
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL JENNIFER RUBIN INJURY
PREVENTION PROGRAM LEAD WITH
DIGNITY HEALTH AND MERCY SAN
JUAN MEDICAL CENTER AND SAFE
KIDS GREATER SACRAMENTO
COALITION COORDINATOR.
AND KATHY BAER.
BURBANK IN BURBANK AND THEY GIVE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
CHILDREN SAFETY AND HEALTH
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
JENNIFER FROM SAFE KIDS GREATER
SACRAMENTO IN OUR PROGRAM IS ONE
OF THE END USERS OF THIS PROGRAM
THAT CALIFORNIA KIDS PLATES
GRANTS AND WE ARE CURRENTLY
PROUD RECIPIENTS OF A THREE YEAR
GRANT FROM THIS PROGRAM BUT I'LL
TELL YOU EVEN AFTER ALL OF OUR
CAREFUL WORK WE WERE ALMOST.
DISQUALIFIED FROM RECEIVING THIS
GRANT THIS YEAR.
BECAUSE WE HAD INCLUDED IN THERE
A SAFE ROUTES TO SCHOOL PROGRAM
WHICH GIVES CHILDREN EDUCATION
ON BICYCLING AND WALKING TO
SCHOOL SAFELY.
BUT COME TO FIND OUT THAT
PEDESTRIAN SAFETY IS NOT ON THE
LIST OF AREAS THAT WE CAN USE TO
EDUCATE.
CHILDREN ON FROM THE KIDS PLATES
FUNDING SO.
THAT WE KNOW THAT CHILDREN NEED
BOTH BICYCLE AND PEDESTRIAN
SAFETY EDUCATION WE DIDN'T
TYPICALLY DO THOSE TOGETHER
KNOWING THAT THEY'LL NEED BOTH
FORGETTING TO SCHOOL SAFELY ONE
DAY THEY MIGHT WALK ONE DAY THEY
MIGHT BACK.
IN SO WE ALWAYS INCLUDE BOTH --
BUT NOW WE'VE HAD TO RE FRAME
ARE GRANT PROGRAM TO MOSTLY
EMPHASIZE THE BICYCLE SAFETY.
SO WE HOPE THAT.
THIS BILL WILL BE PASSED TO ADD
TO THE LIST OF PARTY IMPORTANT
ISSUES.
THINGS LIKE CHILDREN BEING
BACKED OVER IN DRIVEWAYS AND
PARKING LOTS OF SPORTS RELATED
CONCUSSION HEATSTROKE AN INFANT
SAFE SLEEP WHICH HAS BEEN A
TOPIC OF GREAT CONCERN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
SO WE HOPE THAT YOU'LL VOTE I
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS KATHY BRAND
CAM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR CHILDREN'S SAFETY
AND HEALTH.
CO SPONSORS OF THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION BACK IN NINETEEN
NINETY TWO WITH STEVE BERYL
CREATING THIS LEGISLATION AND
WE'VE BEEN EXCITED ABOUT ALL THE
PROGRAMS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
SUPPORT THROUGH THE FUNDING FOR
THIS.
AMAZING PROJECT.
WE HAVE A STATE UNINTENTIONAL
INJURY PREVENTION PLAN AND SO
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS COME FROM
THAT GROUP AND FROM STAKEHOLDERS
AROUND THE STATE WHO ARE WORKING
ON UNINTENTIONAL INJURIES SO
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
MY NAMEIS THE BARREL AND THE
STATE PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION GERMAN
SIXTY HELD JUST HERE TO ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AND TO BE
QUIET FOR CHANGE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH - DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
PLEASE COME UP TO US TO JIM AN
ORGANIZATION.
HI MY NAME IS MOLLY WAGNER I AM
WITH WALK SACRAMENTO WHERE
REGIONAL SAFE ROUTES TO SCHOOL
PROGRAM COORDINATORS WITHIN THE
SACRAMENTO REGION ALONG WITH JAN
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SPELL.
FINA DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS FROM OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBER CENTER PAN PLEASE FEEL
FREE.
THANK YOU MAYBE JUST A BRIEF
COMMENT AS A PEDIATRICIAN
ACTUALLY WORKED WITH THAT MR
BERRA HERE AND SERVED ON I THINK
ONE OF THE INITIAL.
REVIEW COMMITTEES ON FOR THE FOR
THE FUNDING FOR IT FOR THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM SO CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT -- WE'RE
EXPANDING IT TO REALLY THINGS
ARE SO SEE WITH THE CORE
PROGRAMS I MEAN IT'S KIND OF ODD
TO SAY THAT YOU CAN DO A PROGRAM
ON ONE AND NOT THE OTHER BECAUSE
THEY KIND OF GO TOGETHER -- SO
THEY SEE YOURSELF CERTAINLY --
AND SUPPORT WITH THE BUILT
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
OKAY SO A ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH
SELECT TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
CENTER PAN.
AND THE MOTION IS TO DO PASSED
THE SENATE FLOOR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PRODUCTIVE I RITA HI STONE BELL.
BELL I JACKSON PAN PAN AYE.
WIENER [inaudible] THREE ZERO
THE BILL IS THREE ZERO WILL GO
HEAD AND HOLD THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MISTER GIBSON IS HERE AND OKAY
SO UP NEXT IS -- ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN A. B. TEN SIX ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON PLEASE
COME ON UP [inaudible]
YEAH.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENTED IN
YOUR WHAT IS SAID TO HAVE THREE
MINUTES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MMBERS THIS IS MY FIRST
TIME OF PRESENTING FOR YEARS SO.
I'M DELIGHTED -- MEMBERS AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT A SILLY BUILT ON
TEN SIXTY ONE TEN SIXTY ONE WILL
AND ENSURE FAR SO YOU HAVE A
CONSISTENT AND STRONG.
HOME FOUNDATION AND ARE NOT
EASILY REMOVED FROM ONE PLACE TO
THE OTHER FOSTER YOUTH FROM
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
HAS MADE CLEAR THAT ONE OF THE
ROOT CAUSE OF DISRUPTION IN
THEIR LIVES IS THE PLACEMENT
INSTABILITY.
AND LET ME JUST.
PAUSE THERE I AUTHORED ASSEMBLY
BUILD ON TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN
LAST YEAR THE GOVERNOR BROWN --
SIGNED INTO LAW THAT BILL -- PUT
PARTICULAR PART OF PROTECTIONS
IN THAT BILL WE FOUND OUT
THROUGH TESTIMONY OF LAST YEAR
THAT INDIVIDUALS WERE REMOVED
TWENTY THREE TIMES WHAT THAT
MEANS IS TWENTY THREE DIFFERENT
BADS TWENTY THREE DIFFERENT --
KITCHENS BATHROOMS TWENTY THREE
DIFFERENT KINDS OF COMMUNITIES
THAT BREEDS INSTABILITY NOT
STABILITY DOESN'T CREATE THE
FOUNDATION THAT FALL SO YOU'VE
ACTUALLY NEEDS WHAT THIS BILL
WHAT -- TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN
DID IT EXCLUDED THOSE WHO ARE IN
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM WHAT TEN
SIXTY ONE DO IS.
PROTECT VERTICALLY PUT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS BACK INTO -- THE
BILL THOSE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE IN THE JUSTICE SYSTEM THOSE
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO NEEDS THE
CONSISTENCY AND ALSO THE HOME
FOUNDATION THAT IS NECESSARY --
TO GET THEM ON THE RIGHT TRACK
AND THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE BEEN TRAUMATIZED -- THESE
ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ALSO
CAUGHT UP -- IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE THE SAME PROTECTION THAT
ASSEMBLY BILL -- TWENTY TWO
FORTY SEVEN PROVIDES -- TODAY
HERE WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES -- IS MS
BUT NASA HERNANDEZ REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA YOU CONNECTION IN
SUPPORT OF TEN SIXTY ONE GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS VANESSA
HERNANDEZ I SERVE AS
CALIFORNIA'S CONNECTIONS THE
POLICY DIRECTOR -- I ALSO HAVE A
PERSONAL LIVED EXPERIENCE WITH
GROWING UP IN FOSTER CARE
BEGINNING AT THE AGE OF FOUR
YEARS OLD EMANCIPATING WHEN I
WAS.
EIGHTEEN THAT WAS PRETTY
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE -- WHAT'S
BEAUTIFUL AND UNIQUE ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S CONNECTION AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON NOTED IS
THAT WHERE YOU FLOOD
ORGANIZATION SO THAT MEANS THE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO EXPERIENCE CARE
EITHER.
CURRENTLY OR MOST RECENTLY
ELEVATE THEIR PRIORITIES AND
THEIR SOLUTIONS TO THESE
PROBLEMS.
WE'RE IN YEAR TWO OF A FOSTER
STABILITY CAMPAIGN WHICH TO LIVE
STABILITY IN ALL ASPECTS OF
THEIR LIVES INCLUDING PLACEMENT --
INCLUDING RELATIONSHIPS
INCLUDING AN EDUCATION AND
INCLUDED IN SERVICES.
SPECIFICALLY AB TEN SIXTY ONE
WILL EXPAND OUR HARD WORK TO
INCLUDE PROBATION SUPERVISED
YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA -- AND
REALLY WHAT IT DOES IS IT
ENSURES THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A
CLEAR PROCESS FOR INCREASING
STABILITY WITH THE CLEAR POLICY
OF WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN IF A
POLICEMAN CHANGE SHOULD OCCUR.
AND WHAT SHOULD NEVER EVER
HAPPEN MY MEMBERS TALK TALK
OFTEN ABOUT BEING MOVED IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
AND HAVING TO PUT THEIR
BELONGINGS IN TRASH BAGS WITHOUT
ANY.
ANY PROCESS FOR CONFLICT
RESOLUTION OR MEDIATION.
AS THEY CRAFTED THIS BILL THEY
WANTED TO ENSURE HAT THESE
PROTECTIONS AND POLICIES
EXTENDED TO THEIR PROBATION
PROBATION BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
ANNOUNCER THE REST MY TIME WITH
MY COLLEAGUE CRISTINA PARKER.
HI EVERYONE I'M OF THE POLICY
COR NEEDED FOR ON CALIFORNIA
CONNECTIONS AND ALSO A FORMER ON
FOSTER YOUTH AS WELL AT THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH THE
MEMBERS AND REALLY JUST.
COMING UP WITH THIS LEGISLATION --
WE KNOW THAT 40% OF STATES ARE
ABLE ARE UNABLE TO ACHIEVE --
TWO OR LESS PLACEMENT CHANGES
FOR YOU WE KNOW THAT -- IN LA
COUNTY THAT 90% OF YOU FOR FIVE
OR MORE PLACES TO ENTER INTO THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM WE KNOW
THAT 85% OF OUR JUVENILE IN --
AND PRISON POPULATION HAVE HAS
SOME FORM OF ENCOUNTER WITH THE
CHILD WELFARE.
SYSTEM -- PROVIDING ARE USED
ABILITY TO HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
PROVISIONS I'M PROTECTIONS HOME
ALLOWS THEM THE ABILITY TO TO
FLOURISH BETTER -- A LOT OF I'LL
COMES NEGATIVE OUTCOMES ARE
CONTRIBUTED -- TO INSTABILITY IN
HOME PLACEMENT AND SO ALLOWING
ARE USED TO HAVE A HOME
PLACEMENT PRESERVATION ALLOWING
THEM TO HAVE MOVEMENT SECURITY
AND AND BE NOTIFIED ON IN A
JUSTIFIABLE TIME.
IN ORDER FOR THEM TO GET TO
SUPPORT TO THEIR FRANCE TO GET
THEIR NUMBER TO TO TRANSITION
PROPERLY AND TEN X. PLACEMENT IS
VITAL TO ALL OF OUR USED IN ALL
IN ALL OF OUR CONVERSATION SO.
I RESPECTFULLY ACTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE COME UP STATE YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
FROM FIGURE FRAZIER NATIONAL
ASSOCIATIONS SO SHORT CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON WAS DONNELLY WITH
SPIRIT IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON STEPHANIE ISLAND
CALIFORNIA LINES AND CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES I'D LIKE YOU TO
KNOW THAT WE BOTH SUPPORT THE
BILL IN ITS PRESENT FORM AND WE
ARE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR IN
THE C. YC.
ON LANGUAGE THAT WE HOPE WILL
FURTHER STRENGTHEN THESE
PROTECTIONS FOR OUR YOUTH.
THANK YOU TO WE HAVE ANYONE
MESSES AN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
THEKNOT DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
BILL MAHER RIGHT OF AS THE
MARKET SO MUCH LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SENATORS --
I WANT TO ALSO POINT OUT
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY ONE IS A
THOUGHTFUL BILL DEVELOP BY
FOSTER YOUTH THAT SUPPORT FOSTER
YOU -- WHO HAVE ALREADY?
BEEN THROUGH ENOUGH AND SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I THINK IF WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR PAN AND THE MOTION IS TO
DO PASSED TO SEND A PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE A SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RICARDO HI RICARDO I STONE BELL.
BELL AYE JACKSON PAN.
PAN AYE WIENER. THREE ZERO THE
STREETS ARE WHAT WILL GO AHEAD
AND LIKE THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
ITEM NUMBER.
WE ARE.
ONE REMEMBER BONTA COME ON UP.
FEEL FREE -- TO GET STARTED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY
ACR.
ONE OPPOSES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S PROPOSED CHANGES TO
THE IMMIGRATION POLICY KNOWN.
AS PUBLIC CHARGE THAT TARGET ARE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN CAUSE
HARDSHIP TO UNTOLD NUMBERS OF
IMMIGRANTS TRYING TO REALIZE
THEIR OWN AMERICAN DREAM THE
PROPOSED REGULATIONS REGULATIONS
RUN CONTRARY TO CALIFORNIA'S
VALUES.
AND TO BIPARTISAN EFFORTS THAT
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF
SUPPORTING AND WELCOMING.
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES IN OUR
STATE OCTOBER TENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY PROPOSED NEW
REGULATIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
CHARGE DETERMINATIONS.
THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS WOULD
EXPAND THE LIST OF BENEFITS
CONSIDERED WHEN DETERMINING WHO
CONSTITUTES A PUBLIC CHARGE.
BEYOND CASH ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
TO INCLUDE HEALTHCARE HOUSING.
AND FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
PROGRAMS THAT HELP ALL PEOPLE
AND THEIR FAMILIES STAY HEALTHY
WORK THRIVE AND CONTRIBUTE TO
SOCIETY.
THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS WOULD
ALSO CONSIDER THE AGE OF AN
INDIVIDUAL BEING UNDER EIGHTEEN
AND OVER SIXTY ONE WOULD BE
CONSIDERED A NEGATIVE.
THE ABSENCE OF CURRENT
EMPLOYMENT OR LACK OF PROSPECT
OF EMPLOYMENT THE USE OF PUBLIC
BENEFITS ENGLISH PROFICIENCY.
MEDICAL CONDITIONS AND INCOME
LEVEL SO QUITE LITERALLY IF
YOU'RE YOUNG OR IF YOU'RE OLD IF
YOU'RE SICK OR IF YOU'RE POOR.
IF YOU DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH WELL
ENOUGH IT WILL COUNT AGAINST YOU
UNDER THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS.
THESE PROPOSED CHANGES
DISPROPORTIONATELY AND IMPACT
LOW INCOME WORKING IMMIGRANTS
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AND LOW WAGE LABORERS IN
ADDITION OVER 70% OF THOSE
IMPACTED.
OUR CHILDREN THE CHANGES HAVE
REAL IMPACTS THE FEAR OF BEING
DEEMED A PUBLIC CHARGE AND
CONSEQUENTLY DENIED LAWFUL
PERMANENT RESIDENTS OR ENTRY TO
THE US.
OR POTENTIALLY BEING SUBJECT TO
DEPORTATION FOR SEEKING
ESSENTIAL BENEFITS CREATES
ADDITIONAL FEAR WITHIN AND AMONG
OUR IMMIGRANT.
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE THE LARGEST IMMIGRANT
POPULATION IN THE NATION BOTH
DOCUMENTED AND UNDOCUMENTED AND
AT THE SAME TIME.
WE HAVE THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD CALIFORNIA
IS STRONGER WHEN RESIDENTS IN
NEED ARE ABLE TO ACCESS THAT
SAFETY NET WITHOUT FEAR FOR
THEMSELVES THEIR OR THEIR
FUTURES.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR IT AND I VOTE ON A C. R..
ONE WITH ME AT TODAY IS DEEP IN
GET MEASURE WITH CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER AND MIKE
LOCK ASIAN HEALTH SERVICES.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS STEVEN ACNE SO WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER -- WE'RE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR ACR ONE AND GUIDED
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO AND THE
PUBLIC CHARGE RULE -- BY THE IN
THE PROTECTING IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES CAMPAIGN FOR THE STATE
THE PUBLIC CHARGED.
RULES IN A FULL BEGIN RACES
HISTORICAL PARK HAS LONG STOKE
FEAR -- AMONG IMMIGRANTS THE
PROPOSED CHANGE B THE FEDERAL%
GOVERNMENT MARK THE DANGEROUS
AND SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION FROM
THE CURRENT CURRENT RULE GIVEN
THE NUMBER OF AMERICANS TO
ENROLL IN AND RELY UPON THESE
PROGRAMS.
EVEN THE RULES CHANGE HAS YET TO
TAKE A FACT FRONTLINE WORKERS IN
LOS ANGELES AND ALAMEDA COUNTIES
ARE ALREADY REPORTING -- A LARGE
CHILLING EFFECT -- AMASSED A
THRILLER FROM PROGRAMS INCLUDING
SNAP MEDICARE MEDICAID --
MISSILES PROGRAMS ACTUALLY NINE
FOOD IN THE PROPOSAL SUCH AS
WAKE.
I'M CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANTS PAT --
AN ENORMOUS MEMBER -- OF
CALIFORNIA THEY MAKE A STRONG
MEMBERS OF OUR STATE --
CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANTS
CONTRIBUTE FIFTY SIX POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL TAXES
AND TWENTY SIX POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN STATE AND
LOCAL TAXES.
HURTING IMMIGRANTS HURTS ALL OF
US I'M IN FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT OF
ACR -- ONE MADAM CHAIR AN
HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MY CLOCK ON A PLANNING
ASSOCIATE ASIAN HEALTH SERVICES
AGING OF SERVICES WE ARE A
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTER.
BASED OUT OF OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
MR BONTA DISTRICT -- AND WE'RE
WE'VE FOR FORTY SIX YEARS WE'VE
BEEN -- SERVING -- FOR SIX YEARS
WE'VE BEEN IN OAKLAND SERVING --
PATIENTS OF ALL DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS WE CURRENTLY SERVE
TWENTY THOUSAND PATIENTS IN
FOURTEEN DIFFERENT LANGUAGE IS.
A PUBLIC CHARGE WHILE MORE
TENSIONS ON IT AS AS WE SPEAK
I'M IS NOT A NEW ISSUE AND ASIAN
HEALTH SERVICES HAS HAD DIRECT
EXPERIENCE DEALING WITH PUBLIC
CHARGE.
ON THE LAST TIME WAS IN THE
NINETIES -- AN AND AS THIS ORDER
IMPACTS YOU KNOW LEGAL PERMANENT
RESIDENTS ASIAN AMERICANS AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS MAKE UP THE
LARGEST PERCENTAGE.
OF LEGAL PERMANENT RESIDENCE OUT
IN IN THE COUNTRY.
BUT IN THE NINETIES RIGHT AROUND
THE TIME OF WELFARE REFORM WE
HAD A YOUNG MOTHER WHO LIVED IN
OAKLAND AND HAD GIVEN BIRTH TO
TWINS -- BUT SHE WENT HOME TO
CHINA TO VISIT HER FAMILY AND
WHEN HE WAS REALIZE THAT -- THAT
HER MEDICAL COSTS WERE FUNDED BY
MEDICARE ALL SHE WAS A STOCKS AT
SIMPSON'S GO AIRPORT FROM
RETURNING TO THE COUNTRY -- SO
BASICALLY -- WHEN THEY WAS FOUND
OUT THAT SHE WAS AT THAT?
TIME SHE WAS A PUBLIC CHARGE SHE
WAS BASICALLY.
SENT BACK TO TO TO CHINA --
WITHOUT HER BABIES.
ON THIS IS SOMETHING THAT -- THE
COMMUNITY AND MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WORKED ON TRYING --
TO TRYING TO FIGHT -- BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE WERE
UNSUCCESSFUL.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
KNOW AS WE WORK WITH -- PATIENTS
OF ALL THESE DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS MOST OF OUR PATIENTS
ARE VERY LOW INCOME -- WE ALWAYS
TRY -- TO AYE SWAGE FOLKS SPEARS
ABOUT SIGNING UP FOR THESE
PROGRAMS.
SUCH AS MEDI CAL BELIEVING THAT
THEY WOULD BE -- SAFE FROM RIVER
QUESTIONS -- BUT AND AS IT AS IT
HAS BEEN FOUND NOT JUST LAST FO
YEARS BUT WE HAVE ANOTHER IN A
BIG ANTI IMMIGRANT RULE TO FIGHT
AGAINST -- PUBLIC CHARGE YOU
KNOW THREATENS ALL THE HEALTH
GAINS THAT ARE MADE -- THAT THAT
THAT THIS DATES AS WELL AS LOCAL
COMMUNITIES -- HAVE MADE AND WE
AS ASIAN HOW SERVICES
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE COME UP STAGE NAME
AN ORGANIZATION.
KAREN MEMBER SALLY HAD A LOT ON
HERE REPRESENTING NEXT AND
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
FREE TO WALLACE FROM THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND SHOWING SUPPORT.
CAN LUIS REPRESENTING CHILDREN
NOW IN SUPPORT.
MARGOT INDO FROM WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
JIM LINDBERGH ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
A CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
CATHERINE OCCURRED ON ON BEHALF
OF FIRST HAVE CALIFORNIAN FOR
SEVERAL A IN SUPPORT --CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION.
NOW SEEN UNTIL WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU AND I WANNA THANK YOU
THEY'RE ABOUT TO FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD CERTAINLY IS
CHAIR OF THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
WE REVIEW WE TALK ABOUT THE
VARIOUS PROGRAMS WHAT WE TRY TO
DO TO HELP FAMILIES -- HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT THE
PUBLIC CHARGE RULES UNDERMINING
ALL OF THAT.
BECAUSE WE CAN OFFER WE CAN.
NO BUDGET FOR PROGRAMS BUT IF
PEOPLE ARE FRIGHTENED FROM BEING
ABLE.
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
PROGRAMS TO BENEFIT.
FROM THESE PROGRAMS AND WHEN WE
DECIDE DECISIONS TO MAKE FUNDING
FOR THESE PROGRAMS I KNOW THE
CHAIR.
SERVES ON THE SUB COMMITTEE WITH
ME.
THESE ARE PROGRAMS WE LOOK AT
THEM THAT REALY ARE ABOUT.
HOW THE HOW THE LIST THE
FAMILIES UP IT'S IT'S NOT DIG TO
SEE GIVE ME IT'S ACTUALLY
BENEFIT TO THE STATE WHEN THESE
FAMILIES ARE SUCCESSFUL?
AND SO THE IDEA THAT.
WE WOULD FRIGHTEN THEM FROM.
TAKING IT FROM FROM FROM
BENEFITING FROM THESE PROGRAMS
BEING SURE TO KIDS ARE FED HE
SURE PEOPLE OF HEALTH CARE.
BEING SURE THAT SENIORS ARE ABLE
TO GET THE THAT.
IT'S IT'S REALLY AN ATTACK ON
OUR SOCIETY AND AND AND AND OUT
AND OUR OUR STATE WE ALL TO
OFTEN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL -- AND SO FORTH -- ARE --
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD -- WE DEFINITELY IS A
STATE NEED TO PUSH BACK NOT JUST
BECAUSE WE'RE SAYING.
THAT -- THE PEOPLE -- SHOULDN'T
JUST THAT THAT THAT THIS REALLY
IS UNDERMINING OUR STATE OUR
ENTIRE SOCIETY SO NOT JUST THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE DIRECTLY AFFECTED
BECAUSE AND AND WE WE TAKE THAT
IN CONSIDERATION WE DEVELOP
INSIDE MAKE FUND THESE PROGRAMS.
SO AGAIN WHAT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND HOPE
THAT -- I CAN -- PERHAPS BE A CO
AUTHOR AT THE APPROPRIATE TME
WHEN.
IF YOU MAKE SOME OTHER MEN MEANT
TO THE TO THE RESOLUTION THANK
YOU.
NOT BE HAPPY TO MOVE AT THE
PROPER TIME.
THANK YOU SENATOR DR PATH.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CASEY NONE -- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MARC TO FEEL FREE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS -- SENATOR DR PAN IT
BACK THANK YOU FOR LISTENING IN
YOUR CONSIDERATION RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
GREAT TO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR PAN -- THAT MOTION IS TO
BE ADOPTED.
AND SO SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
HER DAUGHTER I RICARDO I STONE.
BELL.
BELL I JACKSON.
JACKSON I'D PAN.
PAN AYE WIENER WIENER AYE
[inaudible] FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO
WAS WAS OKAY.
THE VOTE IS FIVE ZERO AND IT'S
THE BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE -- GOING TO
TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE MOVE TO GREAT WE HAVE A
MOTION -- RESERVE PAN AND WE ARE
TAKING UP.
DO YOU WANT TO GO AHEAD AND LIST
THEM.
OKAY AB AB FIFTY EIGHT AM.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REVERSE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO HOUSING
COMMITTEE.
AB FOUR NINE FOR THEM --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN THE
MOTION IS D. APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE -- EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
SIX THE MOTIONS OF WALDRON THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
AND AC ARE FIFTY NINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON THE MOTION IS TO
BE ADOPTED ALL OF THEM WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- HER DAUGHTER I DON'T
KNOW I DON'T.
DELL DELL AYE JACKSON JACKSON
AYE PAN HI CAN I WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
FIVE THE BILL IS FIVE ZERO AND
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS HAVE
BEEN APPROVED [inaudible]
OUT.
OUR FOCUS AND I WILL BE GOING
OVER ADD ON'S.
AND WILL BE STARTING OFF WITH
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FOUR FOUR
ITEM NUMBER THREE FIVE SOMEONE
OR CULTURAL.
YEAH -- THERE WAS NO MOTION ON
IT.
THE BILL OKAY.
BILL WE GONNA START ASSEMBLY --
THREE FORTY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON AB THREE TOP FORTY FOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE -- ITEM
[inaudible]
M.. ONE IS ON CONSENT INTO IS
BEEN MOVED FROM ITS PURPOSE
PROPOSAL.
RICARDO.
I RICARDO AYE STONE BELL.
BELL AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE PAN.
CAN I A WINNER WIENER AYE. FIVE
ZERO SO THE FOCUS FIVE ZERO AND
THAT BILL IS OUT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASSEMBLY BILL --
FOUR FORTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE -- CHAIR BOWTIE.
AND STONE BELL OR TEASE ME STEM
A JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE WIENER.
WIENER I HAS.
FIVE SO THAT BILL A. B. FOUR
FOUR SEVEN HAS FIVE BOTH AND
ZERO KNOWS THAT BILL IS OUT.
AB FOR SIXTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EGGMAN THE MOTION IS THE
PAST IS JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THE
CHAIR VOTED AYE.
STONE JACKSON.
JACKSON HI THE BILL HAS FOUR BY
VOTERS -- THE VOTE WAS FIVE ZERO
AND THAT A BILL IS OUT. EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO HEALTH COMMITTEE -- CHAIR
BOTH AYE STONE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE WIENER WIENER HI
[inaudible] FIVE ZERO IT'S YOU.
NOW [inaudible]
JACKSON. FIVE ZERO ON THAT BILL
AND THE BILL IS OUT.
THE NEXT BILL IS AB SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN EGGMAN -- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED [inaudible]
AND STONE.
JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE.
THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTE.
SO THAT BILL HAS.
AB SEVENTY SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
ITEM -- TEN YES YOU HAVE.
SO AB SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN FIVE
VOTES FIVE ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE
FORTY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
THE MOTION IS D. PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
THE CHAIR VOTES HI.
STONE.
BELL ABSTAINED JACKSON.
WHICH ONE WAY ON I'M.
EXTRA ME.
NINE FOUR QUIRK QUIRK I'M SORRY
NO BUILDING NOT A STAND I'M
SORRY OKAY OKAY I'M SORRY ABOUT
THAT.
YEAH I WAS LOOKING AYE SKIP THE
LINE.
OKAY -- STONE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE WIENER AYE WIENER HI
THIS FIVE ZERO SURE.
REAL TO TO AB -- NINE SEVEN A
THE AUTHOR IS -- IS GOING TO
COORDINATE WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND WE WILL WORK OUT -- ISSUES
THAT WE RAISED DURING THE
HEARING TODAY.
BETWEEN NOW ANYA ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMITTEE OF REFERRAL SO.
I INTEND TO VOTE YES ON SB. NINE
SEVENTY OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY. EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY SALAS.
THE MOTIONS OF I'M SORRY. FOR
FOR NINE FOUR FOUR WAS FIVE ZERO
SO ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FOUR FOR
THE THAT THE VOTE IS FIVE ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT. EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
THE MOTION IS THE PAST -- TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE --
STONE BELL.
BELL AYE JACKSON.
STATE AND THE YEAH THE
COMMISSION ACTUALLY MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WORK
CONCERNS OR WIENER AYE WIENER
AYE.
AS SEVEN ELEVEN OF YES YEAH.
THREE OR FOUR FOUR ZERO OKAY SO
A. B. NINE SEVEN ZERO THE VOTE
IS FOUR ZERO AND THAT.
BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB TEN
SIXTY ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
STONE JACKSON.
JACKSON HI WIENER.
WIENER HI.
IT HAS.
FIVE THE BILL HAS. FIVE ZERO
BONES AND THE BILL IS OUT.
AB ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN HIS AREA AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
STONE JACKSON.
JACKSON I THAT IN THE LAST.
FIVE THE BILL IS FIVE ZERO THAT
THAT BILL IS OUT.
AB TWELVE THIRTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIU THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE
CHAIR.
HI STONE [inaudible]
JACKSON.
JACKSON HI FIVE ZERO THE BILL IS
FIVE ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
ABC THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIVES BEAN.
THE MOTION IS THE PATH TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE -- CHAIR
BOWTIE STONE JACKSON.
JACKSON HI WIENER WIENER AYE BY
ZERO THE BILL IS FIVE ZERO AND
THE BILL IS OUT.
HEY.
ADAM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH THE MOTION
IS TO PASS -- THE CHAIR BOWTIE
STONE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE.
WIENER WIENER HI.
FIVE THE BILL IS FIVE ZERO ON
THAT BILL IS OUT.
AND ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN ACR ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BY BONTA THE
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED -- AND
ACTUALLY NO I DON'T HAVE TO I
THINGS OUT ALL RIGHT SORRY.
ABOUT POINTS OUT.
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU THIS --
AND OUR COMMITTEE HEARING FOR
TODAY AND THINK SO MUCH FOR
COMING SEE YOU NEXT TIME